Hey,
what's going on?
It's Bill Burr.
It's time for the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast.
And I
just checking in on you.
Just checking in to see how you're doing,
man.
Shit,
by the way.
Um,
you know,
also checking and specifically if they can fucking still hear me.
Anybody who stuck around in North Carolina,
Virginia,
wherever else,
the Carolinas,
the CAC and lackeys.
Yeah,
I had fucking going anywhere.
God Damn.
And I got a fucking fast boat.
All right.
Oh,
that term I took the fucking camper off the back of my camper special.
I welded it to my fucking bass boat.
I am good to go
to see your fucking gator come along my way.
All right.
I have a feast and a new pair of fucking shoes,
water moccasin.
I'll make you into a fucking belt.
Bring it on,
Mother Nature.
You fucking bitch.
Um,
that's what a lot of people,
that's what a lot of people think.
People who are not leaving despite all of the warnings are thinking that's what
they think is going on,
right?
Yeah.
I put on a pair of fucking snow shoes and I walked right across the fucking
class.
Oh,
they're spinning.
I don't give a shit.
I drink moonshine.
Spinning is my natural state mother fucker.
Well,
nature coming over here like some sort of fucking ex wife,
one more fucking money.
Um,
a lot of people think that that's what's going on,
but uh,
you know,
people don't understand that what the bankers did in the two thousands is still
affecting people.
And there's a lot of people who are still upside down in a house that's never
going to be worth more than what they're,
what they owe.
The American dream is over for these people.
And when you're in that situation,
you know,
Eh,
that leads to driving a piece of shit car at least to a whole bunch of shit.
You don't have health insurance and all of that.
So now you're supposed to get into your fucking,
you know,
questionable car and just drive a state away with no fucking money.
You know,
you got kids,
you've got all of this shit.
What are you going to do?
Nine on the other side.
People go,
oh,
well you,
you know,
you,
you lease,
you be alive.
You know what I would do now that I'm driving dry and safe,
I would just drive to a waffle house and I would sit in the parking lot.
You know what would happen?
The security guard at the waffle house,
there's no security.
There's no security.
They just have a fear of a bat phone to the cops at the waffle house.
Yeah,
the waffle house.
They have got to have the most fucking altercations at any just,
I mean,
it's just such a wonderful place.
You go in there to get this delicious,
unhealthy fucking food that just,
it's comfort food.
You know what happens every,
I swear to God,
I don't care who the fuck you are.
Black,
white,
male,
female,
Asian,
fucking Anda Ron deck.
You go in there,
you're,
you're fucking going to get into a fight.
You're going to see a fight.
You're going to have to pick up your fucking waffles and move it out of the way
is somebody slams down on your table like you're in some sort of fucking saloon
in the 18 hundreds.
And you're telling me these people in North Capitol are supposed to drive to
that fucking parking lot?
Well,
Bill,
don't you think that's better than trying to wait it out in a hurricane?
I Dunno,
Dude.
I've never had to do that.
You know,
fortunately I'm not in that financial fucking position,
but um,
you know,
I just don't understand how these fucking bank has got away with that too.
I understand how they did it and then doing it again with these luxury high rise
apartment buildings that they're fucking building everywhere.
What kind of a fucking jerk off rents?
A luxury high rise apartment building.
Okay.
Don't do that by a piece of Shit House.
At least at the end of living there,
you can sell it and get some of your money back.
You may or may not make a profit,
but I'm just saying,
yeah,
you know,
all you Instagrammers.
You know,
what's really interesting that I didn't realize,
uh,
do you know old millennials are,
everybody is looking and like myself included,
you look at college kids,
he's fucking millennials.
They,
they can't do anything for themselves.
They're not millennials.
All right?
Millennials,
the first millennials,
you know what year they were born?
1980.
Okay.
To 19,
I think 95.
So millennials right now or 22 to 38.
And I imagine this a mother uninformed shit heads like me out there who are 38
years old and talking about people who are 18 calling them fucking millennials
when they are not millennials,
but the person is saying it is actually a fucking millennial.
All right,
people now you,
you gotta know what generation you're talking about.
Like,
you know,
it's funny,
I'm actually generation x,
so I was after the baby boomers and that ended in like,
I dunno,
63 or 64 or something like that.
And then generation x went up to 1979.
And what's funny is I did not,
I did,
I,
I don't identify as Gen x.
Know,
generation x to me was,
uh,
the Seattle music scene.
That's when I started fucking here in it.
Um,
I don't think in that,
but I didn't think the baby boomers were like,
hey man,
we got to get out of Vietnam,
man.
Fucking baby killer man.
Right.
Yeah.
I feel like this should be a generation between baby boomers and generation x.
You know,
that generation that like Ronnie James Dio,
you know,
but you know,
didn't listen to the Mamas and the Papas.
All the leads are
proudly supra and the sky is gray.
Like that shit.
Um,
I like to watch your Mama Cat's dance.
She had a fucking cool little two step she used to do.
Um,
anyways,
I don't know what the fuck I'm talking about right now.
I'm just saying,
you know,
uh,
good luck to all of those people.
I'm coming there next week if it's not under fucking water.
I really hope it isn't.
And uh,
you know,
I dunno this,
it's crazy.
This is just fucking crazy.
I know we always had hurricanes and stuff,
but like,
I just hope they're not going to keep getting worse.
And the,
the sheer amount of them,
um,
you know,
I,
there's nothing worse than watching people lose everything,
right?
Um,
if only there was a way to fix this,
mother nature is trying right now,
trying with the only the quickest swiftest fucking solution that's literally,
you know,
metaphorically what she's doing right now going,
I see what the problem is.
I need to drown some of these mother fuckers.
I need to drown a certain amount of them.
Right?
But she's going to have,
the scary thing is she's going to have to do way better than what she's doing
right now because we always worn everybody out.
Oh God.
Right.
The storms come in and everybody gets the fuck out of dodge.
So Mother Nature has gotta be walking around just shaking her head after every
one of these things going on.
I'm telling you,
I don't know.
It doesn't make any fucking sense.
She's like,
Mr Pink.
You know,
tell me we've got a fucking rat.
Okay.
When those alarms go off,
you've got 15 minutes.
I'm telling.
Go to the cops.
They were just there,
man.
They were just there already.
All loaded for bear.
I know Emma.
Right?
I'm fucking positive.
You're like,
I gotta to watch that movie again.
Um,
yeah.
Mother Nature has gotta be we gotta fucking rat in the house.
Okay.
So who's,
uh,
who's Tim Roth?
Terentino's.
Mr. Brown.
Like Mr Shit.
Mr Pink,
Mister Blonde.
Mr. White.
Mr Orange.
Yeah.
She has to find out who are Mr oranges and our Misto Orange is the fucking
weather channel.
You know,
she's got to come in there.
So you like to tell jokes?
Huh?
Giggling like a bunch of girls at the school yard.
Well,
I got a job for you.
MMM.
Anyways,
uh,
yeah,
I have been working out.
I've been eating right and I gotta tell you guys,
uh,
I'm in like the fucking best shape I've been in,
in,
in years and uh,
it is fucking unbelievable.
I know.
People always told me Diet,
it's,
it's 90% died.
95,
85%,
70% die.
Dude.
It's,
it's all diet.
It's all die.
Because like if you can go kick the shit out of yourself and a Goddamn gym,
jump on a fucking elliptical,
you jump on an elliptical for an hour.
Yeah,
Burns 600 calories according to that fucking computer,
which how the fuck it knows how much burning versus somebody else.
You know what happened?
It's an incident estimate.
So you,
you've sweat all over the fucking thing.
You don't wipe it off because you're a selfish cunt.
You go walking out of there,
right.
And then later on that night,
all you got to have like three and a half for Oreo cookies and you just negated
that workout,
done all of that fucking work out the window and you can,
you can fucking do this.
And I got a minute and a half.
You know what it's like.
It's like every year when we are,
whenever we put out these seasons at f is for family.
It takes us like fucking 14 months to finish them.
And then people just not,
not saying,
you know,
that's how kids watching,
not saying I don't want you to do it.
I'm just saying.
Then they just come back like,
hey man,
like when's the next season coming?
Same thing,
same thing.
Um,
yeah,
I got went out.
I,
I'm actually like,
uh,
I am off sugar and salt to the point I asked my wife to go out and get some
almond butter and she got it and I already knew there was something going on
with it where it says you didn't have to stir this shit.
And I'm like,
this doesn't sound like the not just doesn't feel like the natural shit.
So I put it in this smoothie,
two tablespoons of this shit and I meet,
I say let's just fucking sugar in this.
And after like for like five weeks I've been eaten like this.
Like it literally almost made my,
my fucking,
I made like a like a bit into a lemon like Jesus Christ and I never noticed that
beforehand.
So if you're old like me and you want to regain some of your old glory,
you want to drive down the street with the hair is slicked back.
Do you want to put the top down?
You want to tell these bitches what time it is.
Um,
it's all about diet.
Your abs are there,
man.
If you didn't have any,
I don't have abs.
Yes you do.
If you didn't have abs,
you could not sit up in bed.
Yeah.
You know,
you couldn't even roll out of bed.
You need your obliques could not roll out of bed to go downstairs and eat a
chocolate chip muffin or whatever other stupid thing that you're going to do
that's gonna make you break a blood vessel.
When you fucking sit down,
you know,
let's sit down that you do,
when you get really out of shape,
where you,
you lose,
you use your leg muscles,
and at some point it just becomes a free fall into the couch.
You'd give yourself whiplash and you fucking head hits the table that your wife
just had to have.
That was just a little bit higher than the couch.
He put them out.
Fuck right.
And then immediately
what happened,
honey?
Wait,
what the fuck?
A table here.
Okay.
Oh,
I thought it look nice.
And now you're in a fight.
Yeah,
right.
And now you going to work telling your friends that you're not getting along
with your wife and what a fucking bitch she is.
And all of this type of shit and when it really comes down to is you're just,
you're not eating right.
You're not eating right.
See little,
you have to do a trust.
Fall into your fucking couch.
You get a fucking mild concussion on the [inaudible]
giant and table that she just had the hat just had to have it.
And it's slack
for what I'm loving yet.
And southern accent lately,
I kind of disguises that.
It's actually my own ignorance saying it.
Oh No,
I was just doing a character.
Yeah.
Well,
they got a woman doing play by play it in a fail.
Okay.
Oh my God,
you got a big kid then we're nobody's women.
They don't even sport.
Oh,
they do.
Than what a fucker.
Only eight people at a w NBA game.
You explain that to me.
Okay.
So women on the car.
Okay,
why aren't the feminists are,
why aren't these feminists out there to fucking at the Goddamn,
uh,
whatever they're called?
Oklahoma Twat game.
Well,
why don't you watch an episode of the real housewives maybe figure out that's
why they don't show up.
Shit.
Yeah.
Maybe they're three minutes.
It'd be fucking London over a goddamn table.
They ain't give me no camera,
man.
They're not enough camera man.
Break it up.
Um,
I went down a Randy Newman,
a rabbit hole the other night.
Jesus Christ.
That guy's talented.
Huh?
And one that's,
I'm old enough to remember when that song.
Yeah,
show up.
People got no reason.
Shore people got no reason.
Shore people got no reason to live.
And that came out in all these short people got mad and he was,
he was making fun of racism.
The ridiculousness of racism,
right?
It got a little cars go beep,
beep beep.
They got Little Voices Go pee,
Pee,
pee grubby little hands,
dirty little mug.
And people once again took it at face value.
But you know,
having said that,
that song came out and then there was a bunch of people that didn't get what it
was about and they were singing it to short people.
So I dunno,
it was so brilliant on so many different levels.
And I love his voice.
I love the piano he plays and he's done all these,
all these great songs from movies and stuff like that.
And I actually looked up to see if he was a touring anywhere.
Um,
there's some really great footage of them to actually with that short people
think where he's in the studio,
like an incredible credible sense of humor,
you know,
as most,
geniuses that I've seen always self deprecating in that type of stuff.
Um,
it's really funny how that is,
you know,
people who stick just walk around like,
like they're fucking astronauts.
Just supreme confidence,
you know,
always thinking they killed,
let's just,
no fucking clue where it's just like,
it's just one of those fucking things,
you know?
I don't know.
That's always a red flag to me when someone's walking around.
Maybe that's my own fucking thing.
Maybe that's the Boston thing,
like easy,
the Ikea,
don't forget where you came from.
Fucking relax.
Easy.
They're Travolta.
Um,
anyways.
Uh,
okay.
What else?
What else is there to talk about?
I've just been,
yeah,
I was,
you know what?
It was fucking amazing.
I was watching this episode last night,
Sunset Strip and they showed the Coanda pass,
which is where the one on one goes from a Hollywood into the valley.
And um,
there's this old bridge and they were showing like footage of it from the 1950s
and I'd seen this before at a car dealership that had all these old pictures of
Hollywood.
And you see on the one on one between the one on one north and one on one on one
south at the Coanda passes in between the railroad tracks that no longer exist.
And it's always like,
you know,
they used it.
They,
the city,
believe it or not,
from what you know,
the tree huggers saved me on,
had one of the greatest,
uh,
public transportations of any city.
And the conspiracy theory is that the oil company companies and a Goodyear tire
created a corporation.
And they bought up all the street cars,
all the trains and all the trolleys and all that type of shit.
A bought it up and just ripped up all the tracks,
paved over everything and forcing people to all have to drive.
So then they like,
they will,
they would make so much fucking money that they could buy a business as big as
that with trains who can afford to throw out of one fucking train,
forget about a whole city full of them.
Streetcars and trolleys and all that.
Ripped up all the fucking tracks.
I mean,
I don't know what happened,
but there's something happened cause it may,
it makes no sense.
You know,
streetcars were the best.
They know.
They still have them in like San Francisco.
And on talking about the stupid one,
we'd go up the fucking hill like you were.
I mean,
those old school,
the ones that I grew up seeing,
mmm.
I don't know,
but they're actually there.
They're building a,
they are building public transportation out here again.
So,
uh,
we shall see.
It's weird though,
because everything then got built up like everybody had a car.
So,
uh,
like most buildings just to go from the sidewalk to the building is like you
have to go to Vegas and you're like,
oh,
I'm going to walk across the street to this other casino.
And like fucking,
you know,
15 minutes later you're on your hands and knees going like water,
water.
Like it's like an illusion.
It looks like it's right there.
It's right across the street.
It is so fucking far away.
Um,
I know the a,
it's seizes what's hilarious is you can go from the Mirage to the,
uh,
to Caesars and they just have this moving air conditioned sidewalk,
you know,
and there's just all these fat,
sweaty people on it.
You know,
the thing should actually be moving in the opposite direction,
should be a giant treadmill for these people and he should have to walk on it
for 10 minutes,
then it shuts off and rolls the other way.
You should,
you should,
you should have to earn it,
you know?
Um,
they would just be too much,
too much liability.
Somebody has a heart attack,
somebody slips and falls.
So they don't,
they just conveyor belt,
you know,
like cattle off to slaughter Jesus bill.
Why can't it just be people who are just fat and happy and outgoing and you
know,
wearing their favorite loud shirt to go play some craps.
You know what,
you know,
I think you guys might have a point on this one.
Yeah.
Um,
so anyways,
the first week of NFL has gone by.
Yeah.
Now you know what everybody's doing.
Everybody looks at week one and then they just say that's who these people are.
The New York jets.
Are they the favorites in the AFC aged?
Yeah,
they won one game.
Um,
I'll tell you the Patriot look good,
but all of a sudden a texted came back and made it really close.
If I was a Patriot fan,
I wouldn't be a good chat about that.
I don't know about you guys.
Don't you feel like there's about three weeks in?
Yeah.
You know,
you can kind of start to tell like,
okay,
this,
this team is this,
this team is that.
And then there's,
you know,
injuries.
I don't know what the fuck's going to happen,
but I really don't think that the Tampa Bay Buccaneers are going to put a 48
points a week while letting up 40 or the saints going to let up 48.
I don't fucking know.
Right.
Cincinnati you're going to go down by 20 every fucking week and then come
roaring back and fucking waiting.
I don't know.
Maybe they will.
Maybe this is what's going to happen.
MMM.
Tell you right now Cincinnati,
I mean,
if this is what we're going to be most exciting season.
MMM.
Anyways,
so I am going to,
uh,
I'm going to be in town this whole weekend because I have a,
I have a bunch of big gigs coming up,
so I am touring like I used to tour,
so I have like one weekend off until like towards the end of October.
And um,
but this weekend obviously got moved to next weekend,
which was my only weekend off.
So it Kinda worked out.
And,
um,
so my wife was going,
hey,
I got some stuff to do Saturday afternoon.
Do you mind?
You know,
hanging out with our daughter and blah,
blah,
blah.
It's like,
what,
why are you Yada him?
Of course I don't.
Of course we have to hang with my daughter and watch Lsu verse Auburn.
Are you kidding me?
This is a dream.
So fucking dream.
Well,
I ain't going to be a dream to got a goddamn broad announcing the fucking game.
Um,
it would still be a dream.
I don't give a shit.
Welcome ladies.
Welcome to the world of broadcasting.
Uh,
anyways,
uh,
yeah,
I can't wait to my,
we took our daughter over to get some shots,
you know what I mean?
Like,
uh,
I decided to stop listening to Hollywood celebrities and actually listen to
people in the medical field.
So my daughter is getting all the shots.
We stretched them out or whatever.
So she went there to get like her shot.
So she's been there numerous times.
And um,
so now like she knows when we go in there that this is the place where she feels
that needle and stuff.
So she's like on nurse,
she's like,
you know,
when I used to bring my dog to the vet,
same thing.
So I'm trying to make a laugh and stuff.
So we ended up going in there and the woman,
she's great,
she just real quick gets it done.
And um,
my daughter said her first three word sentence after she got the shot,
like she was already crying when we laid back,
anticipating.
And then she got the shot and then she,
uh,
she let out this yell,
just broke my heart and then she looked at the nurse and she just goes,
yeah,
odd John,
bye bye.
Like it was so funny.
Fucking cute.
And it also like broke my heart all at the same time.
I picked her up and she,
you know,
a little hand grabbing a handful,
my shirt like Terry O'Reilly back in the day,
but she's trying to hug me and she just kept looking at the nurse.
The nurse goes,
it's all okay.
That's it.
Yeah,
all done.
And she just kept [inaudible]
go.
Bye Bye.
Let's just like,
it was like a kid going,
I don't you get the fuck away from me man.
Yeah,
bye bye.
Like I can't,
I can't even,
I can't even recreate,
um,
okay.
That moment.
And um,
it's so,
I was so glad that I was there as a dad,
cause I gotta be honest with you.
Like I would stay out in the waiting room because I could not handle,
I was hearing those babies crying then I was just like,
you know,
I,
I don't know that I could,
I can handle,
even if it's a good thing,
watching somebody on any level hurting my kid and I know that they're doing it
for the right thing,
but it was just like,
uh,
so I went in there.
MMM.
And I,
I got through it and uh,
I'm glad I did.
I was glad that I did.
And uh,
it was,
oh my God,
it was so fucking cute.
It was so cute.
Oh,
I'd done well.
I buy
well,
I buy,
just kept saying it like,
like,
like I'm done with you.
Get away from,
I don't want any more
of this shit.
I just can't,
I can't like the emotion in her voice.
I just can't put it into fucking words for whatever reason.
Um,
anyway,
so let's do some advertising here for the week.
My bookie,
everybody,
I call them in every week,
or I call in a,
do they have a plan?
I didn't know what the fuck it is.
I call him.
So God damn busy.
I know.
I call it a couple of people.
I do my pics here.
All right.
My bookie,
you know,
ever since I saw this podcast,
people have been asking me for advice.
Ask me what team to bet on.
The truth is,
I don't know.
It was going to win.
Shit.
I can't even name half the quarterbacks in the league.
I keep forgetting the name of the guy and the Texans who is fucking incredible.
Uh,
Watson,
Dante,
Derek,
deandre,
something,
one of those cool black ID names,
Watson.
Uh,
but if you think,
you know,
you got to check out my bookie.
Remember who you remember.
Who you're betting on is just as,
as important as who you,
who you're betting with.
God,
this copy is written so well and I fuck it up.
Let me try this again.
The truth is I don't know who's going to win,
but if you think you know,
you gotta check out my bookie.
Remember who you bet on is just as important as who you're betting with.
That's why people always tell you to bet with my bookie.
Trust them.
They your best bet.
This season they've been in business fees,
they got great reviews online and their mobile site is easy to use.
My bookie,
you,
when they pay,
this isn't in the copy you lose,
you pay.
Um,
I mean,
yeah,
obviously if you win they pay well.
What does that supposed to be like?
A great thing.
Holy Shit,
you actually pay me if I win.
Wow.
Finally an honest bookie.
Anyways,
they have in game live betting the most rewarding player perks in the business
and for you fantasy football playing guys out there,
you can even bet the under the,
over under on how many fantasy points of player will score each game.
Might most of the,
that's my favorite shit.
The bed,
my book he is other than uh,
other than taking points,
I love taking points.
I love taking the points.
I love the underdog.
You know,
my bookie is slammed with new betters and wants to give everyone the best
service possible.
If you're willing to deposit after 7:00 PM eastern time,
they will give you an additional new,
an additional $25 free play on deposits over $100.
So many people are using this site.
They're actually trying to delay you delinquents from calling in man.
So,
uh,
get an extra 25 bucks if you do it after 7:00 PM eastern time.
Join now at my book.
In my book.
You will match your deposit dollar for dollar use Promo Code [inaudible],
B u r.
R to activate the offer.
That's visit my visit my bookie online today.
That's my bookie,
m Y,
B o,
k,
I.
E.
And don't forget to use the Promo Code [inaudible] when creating your account to
claim up to $1,000 in free play.
And now if you're willing to hold after seven 7:00 PM,
you get an extra $25 using the Promo Code,
Burr B,
u,
r,
r.
And listen after the podcast,
before the throwback clips to my call into the sports gambling podcast.
That's what it is,
was Sean Green and Ryan Kramer.
It says,
mention who you talked about.
Who did I talk about?
Uh,
we talked about the jets.
We talked about Aaron Rodgers.
Yeah.
Um,
and what,
what Keynes did we pick this week?
You know,
I don't remember.
We talked that we talked to all kinds of football.
Um,
I don't,
I don't remember.
I have no idea.
Have no idea.
We talked about the bills.
You talked about the dolphins,
lot of AFC stuff.
And then we talked about the eagles.
We talked,
we talked football people.
All right.
Do you like football?
Listen to the Goddamn podcast.
All right.
He looks,
everybody Hellickson.
There's nobody on the planet like you.
So why would you buy a fucking generic mattress built for everyone else?
Next,
please mention all the talking points below.
Well I was Gunna,
he wrote it.
I'm going to show you.
I'm going to read it.
He looks sleep.
Malik's matches your body to the perfect mattress so you get the best sleep of
your life.
They developed nine different mattresses tailored to the specific body types and
sleep preferences.
Just go to helix,
how
sleep.com/burner to take their two minutes sleep quiz,
and then they'll match you to a mattress that perfectly fits you,
contouring to your body to provide unprecedented comfort and better sleep.
You know,
when you lay on your side and your beer belly just digs into the mattress,
they'll pebble little concave spot there just for you and your belly,
right?
Uh,
you got a lot of chest hair and you sleep on your stomach.
They even have a mattress for that.
36% of Helen's helix sleep customers report better sleep after watching,
switching to their customized mattress from helix sleep.
Right now they're offering up to $145 on all mattresses,
whether you're a side sleeper,
a hot sleeper,
like to a plusher affirm bed.
They've got the mattress that will fit just right.
I sleep on my back.
Yeah.
I lay the,
like I'm in a coffin occasionally on the right shoulder,
may be on the left.
Never on the stomach though.
My back has been too fucked up to lay on my stomach for years,
for decades.
I lay on my stomach and then all of a sudden I'm just like,
ah,
turnover roll out of the bed,
got to start stretching.
Um,
anyways,
get up to $125,
you know,
every time I get on the floor too,
I think there's going to be something under the bed.
I never got over that.
You know,
it's weird.
I'm not really a religious guy,
but I definitely,
uh,
some of the go shit even though I don't believe in that either.
You know what I do and I get on the floor and I started taking this something
looking at me under the bed and I get over it.
I just give whatever's under the under the uh,
bed,
the finger,
you know,
cause I figure if there's something underneath it and I give it the finger,
it's going to kill me.
That's going to be over.
Right.
And then if it doesn't do anything like does he have enough that underneath
there or it's a fucking,
it's a fucking bitch.
It's a pussy,
right?
It's one of the bitch coaches.
Um,
okay.
Uh,
whether you're a side sleeper,
a hot sleeper,
like a plush or affirmed bed.
They've got the mattress to fit you just right.
Get up to $125 off helix,
helix,
sleep.com/bird.
That's h e l I x sleep.com/ [inaudible] for $125 off your mattress order.
Oh look who's here.
Bodo
[inaudible] Miyan D's.
Get the fuck outta dodge.
Doodoo due to Mandy's me undies.
You're going to drown in your lodge.
When Nate tell you to leave your state drive to a waffle house.
It'll be great and your balls will be nice and soft and there'll be fucking dry
cause you're,
we'll be out in the flood zone.
Then you go back to your moldy house.
Yeah.
And look for Sean Penn.
He'll be driving around in his boat.
All right,
me undies.
Uh,
you've heard me obsessed silver me undies.
You've heard me talk about how much they are three times softer than cotton and
come with fun new prints each month.
But I got a big scoop that I'm so excited to share with y'all.
Youngies just gave their membership a massive upgrade.
Members,
we'll also pay less for everything on me undies website with special member
pricing.
That means if you want a second pair of me undies,
a Bralette or lounge pants,
you'll pay less than anyone else.
Uh,
what the fuck are lounge pants?
I want some the membership.
I don't like.
Listen,
don't send me any me undies.
Okay,
I got enough shit.
I'm trying to fucking get rid of stuff.
Lounge pants,
all that.
How do you lay off lounge pants,
honey,
could you,
well,
what do you,
were you asking me to do those stuff for sweet kid?
You see him in my lounge pants.
What did we say?
What I have on my lounge pants and meet some fucking loud shit.
Well,
maybe I do have to yell because RV seated here at the fucking first time.
Oh,
Godi have mothers go to your mother's.
You wanted to go there anywhere.
Yeah.
How could my mother never comes over?
Huh?
All of a sudden.
What?
You fucking busy one of my relatives,
right?
Lounge pants by me undies.
You'll pay less than anyone else.
The membership comes with no strings attached.
You can switch styles,
skip the month or cancel any time that they come with a hundred percent
satisfaction guarantee.
If you don't love him,
just send it back for a full refund.
Me undies has a great offering her for a great offer.
For my listeners,
my listeners,
for any first time purchasers,
when you purchase any me on,
you get 50% off the free shipping.
This is a no get 50% off a pair of the most comfortable undies you will ever put
on to get your fifth to get your 15% off your first pair of free shipping and
100% satisfaction guarantee.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash [inaudible] that's [inaudible] dot com slash bar
[inaudible] dot com slash burp.
All right,
that is the podcast.
All right.
The Thursday after new podcast.
Now,
now you get the little transition music and then you get an x.
You get two extra fucking things here.
This is incredible.
You're going to get to listen to me talking to what the hell did it go?
Um,
the sports gambling podcast was Sean Green and
Ryan Graema.
Um,
you get to listen to my pitch.
You get to listen to my picks of the week.
I actually think my lock of the week was that someone was going to say something
disparaging about the,
um,
the,
uh,
the female announcer and I add as far as I can tell,
nothing really happened.
You know,
I was just fun,
right?
The Ana mine,
I said,
good luck to everybody.
What?
They should have a transgendered person in that fucking do it,
dude.
As long as they're still playing football,
I don't give a fuck.
All right.
And as long as you know what you're talking about,
I don't know why I don't care.
What's between your legs,
what you used to have there,
what you attached,
what's your carved out?
I don't,
I don't give a fuck.
Just please,
for the love of God,
know what you're talking about and enhance the experience.
Don't take away from it.
Right.
In other words,
do the exact opposite of what I do on my fucking podcast.
All right.
Have a great weekend.
You [inaudible] uh,
let's go Lsu.
Yeah.
Actually,
Randy Newman has a song called rednecks where he actually a,
he's actually making fun of northern liberals.
Uh,
when it comes to racism,
how everybody acts.
Like,
you know,
all the racism is down south.
It's a song you could never write today because of the lyrics.
But you know,
if you actually knew what he was talking about,
um,
but there's this,
there's a line in there.
Got College kids at Lsu,
uh,
go in dumb.
Come out dumb too.
So I figured people of Alabama would like to listen to that one.
Right?
Maybe Mississippi.
It's always the state.
Next door.
Arkansas.
I've noticed like,
states always think the state next to him was fucking stupid and they're better,
you know,
which is why rough and rowdy is so fucking tremendous.
They're the only people I've ever seen that really exploit
that state to state rivalry at the level that people really want to take it to.
All right.
We play football because it's illegal to just go and beat the shit out of each
other.
But with rough and rowdy,
like when they had it down in the Carolinas,
I had no idea how much people in South Carolina in North Carolina didn't care
for one another.
You know,
and literally thought because that,
because of that invisible line,
if you were on the other side of it,
that meant that you was some sort.
Yeah,
you were less than them.
It's fucking tremendous.
So the next rough and rowdy event,
unfortunately I'm not going to be there,
but you can bet good and God damn well,
I'm going to order it and I'm going to tape it and I'm going to just sit down
with my Miller highlights and I'm gonna Watch it.
Um,
the next one I believe is in Kentucky and,
uh,
it's on October 5th,
but I have a Gig in Boston that night,
so I won't be able to do it.
Please.
Uh,
please on tune in j Portnoy,
big cat,
almost hilarious people over there.
All right,
set.
Is it,
um,
enjoy your weekend.
You constantly,
and I'll talk to you.
[inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
Eh,
yours.
That's the way you're doing.
Play the
[inaudible] bonus.
Phonathon
maybe
finger bill burr on the sports gambling back.
This is brought to you by my book.
He,
Daddy G my book.
He is the leader in online sports books.
Use the Promo Code Bill bets for a 100% deposit bonus.
Play when and get paid at my bookie Daddy G.
Okay.
Joining us on the line,
Bill Burr.
Bill.
I know,
uh,
I know you said you had some travel and to do this past Sunday,
were you able to enjoy NFL week one?
Yeah,
I watched the,
uh,
the Patriots game.
I love my direct TV was kind of cutting in and out for whatever reason.
Um,
so I watched a little bit of that.
I saw a little bit of the jets and I watched John John Gruden's return and I was
loving the first half.
It was great seeing them there.
I thought it was funny when we say and he couldn't,
he wasn't gonna be able to write to these younger kids and they got rid of all
the young kids.
He has like the oldest team in the NFL.
I that's either going to be a,
I think I actually,
I think think it's going to just kind of a genius move on his part.
Yeah.
It seemed to be a bold play to kind of do what Curtin did and obviously the
second half didn't work out.
I mean last week we hit on it.
Uh,
I think your lot cash that the,
every sports announcer will be coming out with the sky is falling down and that
certainly seems to be the case for the Raiders.
And then on the positive side,
the jets,
well why the rate?
I mean the Raiders play like the first half state,
they weren't,
they will met some really good rams team.
I mean I like the Raiders event like,
like you know,
a slapstick forever.
I think for week one I that was,
I would be happy with that if I was a Raiders fan.
I've even known what that second hips,
they didn't look clueless.
I mean it's only week one.
Yeah,
I know in the Jetson now like you know they're already going,
you know
whatever that USC guy did.
Yeah.
They like,
you know what he did week one that Tom Brady did this first week and it's just
like,
you know,
I'm not,
I'm not saying that that guy isn't going to be greater I think,
but like,
like I don't think you really even know what's going on until after three weeks
as far as just like,
all right.
I mean look at that,
that Tampa saints game 48 40 I mean,
is that what they're going to be doing each week?
I don't know.
He ain't giving up 40 or the other way around at this.
That just seems like sometimes it's just weird games and I don't think
Stafford's going to throw five interceptions.
He just,
you know,
sometimes you just have a bad game and,
uh,
I dunno,
that was,
that was that jets game.
I was,
um,
you know,
I mean,
obviously if they do that every week they're going to be world beaters,
but I got a feeling that they're not going to be.
Yeah,
I agree.
And just as a,
as a,
as someone who grew up as the jet says,
like the little brother team just listening them,
Chad,
j e t s jet,
Cha Cha,
it's like calm down one win.
And that the worst heartache of the week so far is the,
you know,
Brett farbs first pass in the NFL was an interception too.
It's like calm down,
calm down there.
The jet there,
the jets,
just too many channels.
They have to overhype everything.
But what the judge did was obviously really impressive.
Uh,
and I,
you know,
I mean,
Afc East Guy,
so Miami went to when the buffalo good Lord Build.
So yeah.
Um,
buffalo good Lord.
They ever going to turn it around,
but it's only one week.
Who knows.
But I mean,
well,
you know,
it's funny that they set out the Patriots,
uh,
for the first time since 2016 or not favorites next week.
And,
um,
I was sick of like,
well,
2016 isn't that long ago,
you know?
Yeah.
So,
I mean,
I guess it is as far as like,
you know,
being a favorite,
all of those,
all of those games,
but uh,
you know,
they made it seem like it was going to be a decade ago.
Yeah.
I mean,
New England,
they came out,
they took care of business against the Texans,
who wasn't,
it was a,
it was Kinda,
it was,
it was a weird game.
It didn't,
it,
you never thought the Patriots were going to lose,
but the spread seemed like it might come into a play at Gronk,
obviously looking great.
I mean,
and then hold them,
we'll let them back in the game and then I'm just sitting here with like six
minutes ago.
Like,
are they going to tie this up?
why do we get into this situation?
I kind of like,
you know,
I was very impressed with our defense.
Um,
you know,
containment of their quarterback.
Like never I can remember his fricking name that God's not.
Yeah.
Watson.
Um,
but I,
I our special teams,
um,
of let up a lot of yards.
It seemed like every time they ran it back they've got at least to the 30.
Um,
I dunno,
we shall see.
But our defense looked pretty soluble a now it's only one week
they finally got rid of Patricia took that garbage defense to Detroit.
Oh Man.
Oh yeah.
I mean if you're,
if you're a lions fan and you watch the Superbowl and then week one Monday night
against the New York jets,
you can not be happy.
It's like you brought in a defensive coordinator.
The defense sucked and you kept the offensive coordinator because you liked the
chemistry and they looked like horrible dog shit.
So I don't know a lot of good regression angles in the NFL for me too.
Exactly.
I mean that's when you're talking about pet in the NFL,
that's what you,
that's kind of what you have to do.
You have to look to opportunities to fade some crazy outcome.
Like you said,
Bill with the box putting up 48 points on the road.
I have a feeling Ryan Fitzpatrick isn't going to do that week to just gut
instinct.
There's a reason he's not doing that every week.
It's,
it's a fluke.
Crazy shit happen.
Yeah.
That's the same thing.
But I don't know.
It's,
it was,
yeah,
it was definitely a weird,
it's a lot of weird games.
Um,
but we'll,
we'll still hold on until a tie here in the last time I saw a tie.
Lord.
Well,
what's funny is I was,
one of the things I bet on this season is there will be no tie this see,
I want on it last year,
the first week of the season,
Bam.
And of course it's the fucking browns.
It paid like one and a half to one.
It just seems like there's,
like you said,
there's never a tie even now with only the 10 minute over time it seems like
it's,
and it's the NFL,
they're not going to end in a tie.
Come on.
Yeah.
They should switch it to the college football rules for overtime because that's
such a more exciting way to finish the game.
And then you never end up with a tie one and a half one.
Does that mean you got to beat up the bet to 50 to make a hundred?
No.
So I w I bet a hundred and I would win one 50 plus my original bet back.
So it felt,
it felt like the right,
I mean I,
you know,
obviously it's a losing bet.
So hindsight is is what it is.
But yeah,
ties are just,
both teams really tried to lose the game.
That's what we were actually out in Las Vegas hanging out in the sports book
when they missed that field goal to end the game and the tie and it was,
the sports looks great for dramatic wins and losses,
but dramatic ties.
It's just no one's happy.
Even if you had Cleveland plus three and a half,
you still wanted to see them hit that field goal just to just to end the
suffering.
It was like we were at a strip club and a dude walked out on stage.
I,
everyone's just like,
ah,
trying to make sense of this.
All right,
we'll have,
who would have thought you'd say that this is their,
this is their best start and over what,
14 years best starts since 2004.
Oh man,
they were loving that stat.
All right,
well let's,
uh,
let's get into some of these spreads.
Of course,
the spreads are brought to you by my book,
Daddy g,
the one of the safest online sports books.
Use the Promo Code Bill bets for a hundred percent deposit bonus.
They got it all over their end game.
Wagering the prop builder,
play Wayne and get paid.
My bookie dad Agee Promo code bill pets.
All right.
First game to talk about New England patriots.
They head into Jacksonville where the Jaguars right now are a,
uh,
the pats actually our favorite in this game.
They're a a three point favor right now,
Jack.
Yeah.
Jags are the home dog here.
We're looking at a rematch of the AFC championship,
although it was played in New England and that Jacksonville Bill,
are you worried about the,
the jags defense here on the road?
Yeah,
Tom Claflin is and you know,
obviously she's,
he's beaten us twice in super and every going to cut quickly.
He's turned that team around everywhere and the guy goes eight that,
you know,
fright from the back his days when he's at Boston College.
I'm a big fan of Tom Costs and she's getting three points at home and it did
Jaguars defenses as good as that.
I would take,
I would take the Jags,
I wouldn't be afraid I would take the Jaguars,
uh,
getting tiny at home.
Um,
you know,
they,
I don't know.
I just think there were really tough team and uh,
we'll see.
We'll see.
I mean,
obviously I'm rooting for the Patriots,
but we're talking money here.
Yeah,
exactly.
Can't mess around to keep the lights on here.
I would take the jaguars getting three.
Yeah,
it does feel like that's the smart play.
I mean,
you touched on it last week,
shown on the Patriots.
Generally aren't playing their best ball in September.
And guess what,
this is the biggest game on the schedule for the jags after blowing that game in
New England.
So I mean,
look,
the,
the paths led a Houston team that played pretty poorly,
uh,
get back in the game and Watson was not himself.
So I'm going to,
I'll say a,
unless Bortles completely Bortles it,
uh,
I think the Jags jags are gonna win this game.
Yeah.
It,
and you talk about Tom Coplin style,
the way to beat New England is the,
to try and get pressure on Tom Brady with just using your defensive line and not
blitz in a bunch of guys.
The jags have that strong defensive line that might be able to,
well,
my dominate the game,
but certainly pressure Brady enough and uh,
I think what the paths have going for them is Leonard for net looks like he's
going to be out for the jags.
Jags don't have a ton of offensive weapons.
Honestly,
I think the play in this game maybe,
uh,
maybe to go under,
it feels like it's going to be a little slug match here.
But I'll take the jags catching three in a rematch at home.
Yeah,
I know God hates Jack.
Sean.
Remember that a next step
then the under,
since this everybody throws hand offs now.
You know what I mean?
I just can't
or receive or past five years.
I just,
I always get nervous button,
the button,
the under from before.
If you want to fade.
Recency,
just take the under in every game.
I feel like they're there.
They're may be an over adjustment to the total is after that point.
Yeah.
Everything.
I mean the fantasy,
everything.
The scoring was just off the charts.
Yeah,
it is.
It is tough to bet the under,
I mean just for the entertainment value alone to just root against every play to
succeed.
But
I don't think anybody's ever going to break Emmitt Smith uh,
time rushing record.
They just did.
Opportunities just aren't there anymore.
No.
Yeah,
I mean it's,
I think it's going to be really hard for any running backs to set marks going
forward.
Cause I mean,
half their touches are going to be passes.
He's going to be like that guy who's won the most games.
Like whoever won the most games in NLP histories.
It's like in the five hundreds like it's just like it's gonna.
It's gonna seem that daunting.
Like it was a different era.
Yeah.
Besides saw young guys are head
is over 800 starts.
They're not doing that anymore.
No,
they,
yeah.
I mean they're never going to come even close to getting there.
Yeah.
You pitch a whole double header.
They were men die a march.
They were,
they were men back then though.
Oh,
they had a stake giant cigar and called it a day.
A little bit of a beer league,
you know,
let's be honest.
Yeah.
I mean you look at Babe Ruth,
he does.
He does strike you as your uncle at a softball game who can just crush it.
We just had a little bit of hand eye coordination.
Yeah.
I used to play in a softball team when I was working in a warehouse and they
always had these,
these ringers would come out and they all look built like Babe Ruth,
a little skinny legs,
big beer belly.
And they would just get up and they would turn that torso and the thing would go
a mile.
Yeah.
That's like,
I mean,
that was Cecil fielder,
you know,
he was,
he was the modern day version of that meal.
All right,
next up we got the New York giants heading down to Dallas.
Right now it's sitting at a even minus three here.
Both teams started out.
Oh,
and one neither.
Neither looked great too.
Uh,
yeah.
I mean,
giants lost at home to the jags.
Cowboys lost on the road to the panthers.
Spill.
Which way you lean in here.
I hate this game.
I know.
Same here.
I hate this game where it's just like,
like the cowboys at,
I dunno,
they're at home.
It's a deficient rivalries to the Games are always closed.
You can never bet against Eli.
Eli doesn't seem like it gets excited until like November,
but they got that running back.
Jesus,
am I going to go giants,
giants with Tom Claflin and then I'm going to go,
they're going to go,
I think,
you know,
they beat us twice.
So,
I mean,
I can't,
I got to keep it.
I,
uh,
I believe it here,
right?
And I think,
uh,
the Dez Bryant hangover and this whole,
whatever the hell they've done,
reef formation of the cowboys is the hangover lasts for at least three weeks.
I'm going with the giants.
Kramer,
I'm assuming you're going to be back in your giants as well.
I also believe in Ely.
I appreciate all these mentions of Tom Coughlin and the Superbowl wins.
And you see how excited Ryan is getting on the other end of this.
But I mean,
here,
here's the thing,
right?
I,
I think I was talking to my dad today and I was like,
you know,
I actually wasn't that upset.
The giants played fine.
They played a really good team.
Uh,
they played a really good defense.
More importantly,
and the offensive players got theirs.
They just,
they were picked six away.
So,
uh,
but what I would they saw on the Dallas cowboys game was the team that even when
Kiki was out of the game,
this team struggled to anything and deck as we know,
Sean Dakota,
Prescott not the best quarterback in the NFL.
So Eli has historically played well in Dallas.
I'm going to keep throwing that out there and yeah,
no,
of course.
You take the,
take the giants before it gets off at three.
Yeah.
As much as it pains me,
I'm going to take this,
I'm going to take the giants getting three points.
You look at the cowboys,
they're only,
they got seek and that's it.
They're authentic line isn't the dominant force that it was an eight.
They have no skill positions to help deck out.
Uh,
on that offense.
I think they're just going to have trouble putting up points and the giants,
their weaknesses,
he offensive line.
Obviously the jags were able to exploit that.
I don't see the cowboys being able to get enough pressure on Eli and listen,
it is Sunday night,
Sunday night football.
I think your Buddy Odell Ryan,
in spite of the fact that he has not won a game since he went on the infamous
boat trip,
I think they get a victory down in,
uh,
down in Dallas stadium there.
So I'll,
I'll take the giants plus three.
I don't feel,
I don't feel great about it because Dallas coming off at a loss.
Maybe they rally,
but I am just still not a believer in chasing Karen at all as a head coach.
I think Dakota Prescott sounds like some country singer on one of those,
uh,
American idol shows
so true.
I mean,
it's just,
it's,
it cracks me up.
His name's Dakota vote now for Dakota.
Prescott.
It's the fact that he is also Prescott.
Yeah.
You could be Dakota something or something.
Prescott,
but did code of Prescott.
That's a tough one,
man.
I,
you can just like,
you're just born with an acoustic guitar in a cowboy hat.
Second you come out.
Yeah.
You imagine it's a,
yeah.
He's like a chick with a cutoff flannel shirt with some like short jean shorts
coming out with the acoustic guitar ready to wow you with their latest
rendition.
Well,
that's another way of looking at it.
I didn't tell him in daisy.
Well,
he's a,
he is.
He is a woman.
In my scenario bill,
he's done.
He's done and shown and let's not forget that Dak Prescott,
sorry.
Dakota's Prescott.
Favorite Song is drops of Jupiter by train.
That was a little known nugget about Dakota.
That was the trivia fact.
We dug up.
All right,
last game of the week.
Now we'll be breaking down here.
Kansas City chiefs come off a nice win on the road against the Los Angeles
chargers.
Now they're heading into Pittsburgh.
Obviously Pittsburgh coming off that ugly,
ugly tie against the Cleveland browns.
Right now my book,
he has the Pittsburgh Steelers as minus five favorites home
bill.
Which way you lean in here.
You know,
I didn't see a second of that.
Steel is game.
I don't know how was Big Ben Looking?
He looked pretty like typical road,
Big Ben like through five one five interceptions.
I five interceptions.
I'm turnovers.
Maybe?
No,
I think he,
I think he through maybe four or five pics.
They had six turnovers overall,
but he didn't look
good at all.
I liked the Steelers at home.
I don't like that number though.
Here's what we picked a perfect number where you just sit on the fence.
Which way am I going to fall?
Uh,
you know what I say to steal his crew are going to cover the chiefs.
So the chiefs,
the chiefs,
you know what I mean?
Until they,
not the chief's,
the,
the chief's.
The Steelers.
That's still the Steelers.
I,
I mean,
I just thought,
I'm just going to be like historical betting here in the first couple of weeks.
I mean,
I don't know who anybody is at this point.
Well,
I think,
you know,
talk about overreaction.
Oh my God.
Big Ben was horrible.
He's always bad on the road.
Oh my God.
They,
the timer,
they tied the browns.
Oh,
lovey on bill.
Big Ben.
He's old school.
Take a hit.
Like that guy,
you know,
he's just,
and he,
he gets it done in the big moments of the games and I don't know,
I,
I believe in that guy still.
Yeah,
he looks like
he plays well in the home at home.
And that's why I like this.
Like we're gonna fade public perception,
but the Steelers stink and we're going to fade public perception that the chiefs
are going to win the Superbowl because Oh my God,
Andy Reid started.
Well again.
Uh,
I mean,
look,
this is a classic fade recency or this line opened at seven Sean and people that
have been crushing the chief side of this.
So,
wow,
let the number come down.
I'm also going to be on the Steelers,
Sean.
I think this is a great kind of fade recency both ways here.
Wow.
It's going to be a clean sweep are all integrated and all these pics.
I love the Steelers at home coming off a,
I mean,
not a loss,
but it may as well be.
Then you come home for their home opener,
you know they're going to bounce back.
And then meanwhile you've got the chief's coming off a huge road victory to go
to the other side of the country in Pittsburgh.
My home smelling himself like,
come on.
Yeah.
And we watched that.
We watched that game.
Ryan,
the uh,
chief secondary looked horrible.
Hey,
I don't want to be at geography Snob,
but they're not going to the other side of the country to Kansas City,
to Pittsburgh.
That's,
you know,
to just into the east coast.
I was,
I was factoring in the them going out to la,
then to Kansas City,
then out to Pittsburgh.
But yeah,
a lot of trash,
a lot of traveling plane.
Come on.
They've got a connection in Poughkeepsie United in the middle seat.
You know,
I think there'll be all right.
They're going to have Chris
next.
They're not,
they're going to be dehydrated from all those salty peanuts.
I,
I just,
I just think it's a good spot for Pittsburgh add home home opener for the Kansas
City defense is just their passing defense in particular is just horrible.
And it's a passing league.
I just feel like Pittsburgh is going to be able to throw all over him.
Anything you say with confidence that they're passing the stinks?
I'm not giving you crap if just
after one week.
Well,
I'll give you two reasons.
One reason is I watched the game and I saw that the chargers receivers were wide
open a number of times that just dropped easy casual balls.
And then two,
other than that,
my other mother deeper reason is I sit next to a chiefs fan at work and everyday
he opens up his laptop and starts reading blogs and just goes,
our fucking secondary fucking sucks.
So I'm kind of using that as well.
Okay.
I'm,
I'm convinced.
So one year over.
All Right,
Bill,
do uh,
you know,
wrap things up here.
You hit with your lock last week you were,
you were two and one with your picks.
The lock of course was that the sky was falling down or that the,
the announcers all proclaimed the sky was falling down.
Yes.
Hopefully we get that three and oh,
this week.
But what's your,
what's your lock prediction for a NFL week too?
Uh,
one person tweets that women should not be play by play announcers and by
Wednesday,
oh,
I guess it's a,
I got another two days.
Somebody is going to say something.
Oh yeah,
somebody will say something and then it's going to become this huge thing.
And then I think by this time next year,
all play by play.
People will be women.
That would be,
that's that.
That is my luck.
Lock it up.
Doris Burke will be doing it.
It's finding a way as a Jew,
as a joke,
I was joking with my buddy,
I go,
dude,
Burt Reynolds died in the play by play on Monday night.
Football is a female.
I go,
it really is over.
We had a great run.
So as,
as a joke,
I actually looked at the elks club going like,
I'm maybe just see what the elks club that's in men's club or whatever and
looked it up.
And in 2005,
first of all,
I looked it up in the picture was of a woman.
When you go to the whole website of number,
like they sued in 2005 and one so like even they've even infiltrated obviously,
I mean arguably the biggest group of jerk off men in the country.
I mean you're literally talking to take away like the hats with the little
tassel.
See?
Yeah,
it's hilarious.
Like I looked it up,
I would never join it,
but I was just,
I just was going to get a check out of the fact that there was one place left
where you could just chill out and not have to adjust your behavior and the old
gentleman,
no help scope.
It's over.
It is over man.
It was the elks club and Augusta national and then both those had been
infiltrated.
They're now no longer all male.
All right.
I know we had a hell of a run dude run.
Yeah,
man.
Really did have a hell of a run.
Hey,
all every dynasty must come to an end.
Tens of thousands of years.
I think
Roy Emmett and uh,
what's his face?
The urban.
The triplets.
Yeah.
We weren't a three headed monster for a long time.
Well,
this is a lot of people are seeing,
this is a rebuilding year for men.
You know,
we're,
we're open to get the number one draft pick took a lot of heat loss,
a lot of uh,
lost a lot.
I took a lot of L's out there.
Yeah.
We're going to try to forget about last year and uh,
you know,
if we're going to hit reset,
we've got Jon Gruden back.
He's back for different times so much.
Jon Gruden face.
I can't wait.
Oh Man.
It was,
he was loved seeing him back then.
It was so funny how like he was just kind of a different guy in the broadcast
booth and then the second he put the headphones back on again.
He just wanted a break back to the chuck you face.
I loved it.
Yeah.
The thing that was frustrating about him as an announcer was that clearly he
thought about getting back into coaching so he wouldn't bad mouth guys on the
air and he just loved everyone at ease.
A great guys.
You guys look at this guy and then as soon as he's got that headset on,
you could just see him screaming and yelling.
He was,
he was just so pissed at cars.
We got that job.
He cut half the team.
And I thought you said you love me.
The broadcast booth.
Yeah.
Not on the claims paid it.
All right,
well let's see how we do gentlemen.
Uh,
I'm going to get more bold with my predictions is once,
you know,
hopefully,
what am I actually,
my show's got moved this weekend because of that hurricane,
which hopefully goes out to sea.
I'm,
I supposed to work in Virginia and South Carolina.
So I'm hoping that,
you know,
a lot of those people are probably still upside down in their houses because of
the piece of shit bankers.
So the last thing they need is a hurricane to hit the house.
That's never going to be worth more than what they owe on it.
Screwed by the insurance companies as well.
Yes.
Yeah.
For the trisector.
So,
um,
uh,
that's what I'm thinking about this week.
I'm supposed to be there the following me,
but I,
but the other side was I will be home and have enough time to watch the games.
So hopefully a silver lining in.
Now shout out to Dakota Prescott.
Love it.
All right,
and obviously a checkout bill,
birdeye.com for all the upcoming tour information.
And of course,
uh,
check out my book e.
Dot.
Agee Promo Code.
Fill beds for that 100% deposit bonus.
Play when and get paid my bookie.
Dot.
Agee.
Yeah,
buddy.
That's his
[inaudible].
Hey,
what's going on?
It's built bar and it is the Monday morning podcast
for Monday,
September 13th,
2010 what's going on?
How are you?
You're feeling good.
I'm going to try to pretend like,
am I actually went out drinking last night and a little banged up,
a little banged up.
It's actually 10 oh one east coast time.
I'm in New York City.
This is a the biggest week of the year for me.
Um,
I'm back here doing press for my,
I'm new one hour special.
Let it go.
That comes out in premiers.
They switched the date on me.
It is now it's Sunday,
September 19th at 11:00 PM.
So,
uh,
please tune in.
Please listen,
please watch.
Please invite other people over.
Why don't you have a little fucking stand up comedy party?
Don't they have those?
They have super bowl parties.
You know,
we invite a bunch of broads over and they talked during the game and they shut
up during the commercials.
I kind of liked that one.
How much do you think that that went Costa dated?
Um,
anyways,
yes,
I'm in town this week and I'm going to be doing the opiate Anthony Program,
my fucking favorite.
Um,
I'm going to be doing that.
I believe I'm going to be doing something on the versus network.
I am going to be talking to anybody with a microphone this week doing my gosh,
darndest to try and get people to listen to my fucking podcast.
But how many podcasts?
See what happens when I multitask to get people to watch my specials.
And,
um,
I'm gonna apologize for the lack of funny up until this point already right out
of the fucking gate,
just because I have to make sure I get this information out at the beginning of
the podcast.
All right,
so my special September 19th at 11:00 PM on comedy central.
Um,
please go ahead and watch it.
And if you want to preorder my DVD,
look into your heart.
If you want to order this thing for an unbelievably,
ridiculously,
almost an embarrassingly low price,
you can order the fuck that thing for like $13 in like 29 cents on amazon.com.
I don't know how the fuck they came up with that price,
but I got to admit I felt a little insulted.
You know,
why don't you just fucking give it away?
amazon.com
so there you go.
Why don't you buy to look at that?
Because right after that it's going to be 1999.
So then if you actually go out and buy two,
then if you come out to my show,
you'd be like,
Dude,
stop bitching about your free fucking podcast because I actually bought two year
DVDs and now be thinking in my head,
wow,
this guy dropped 40 bucks.
What a good shit.
And you'll be laughing because in the back of your head you're like,
actually I dropped 26 and change,
you know,
26 and change.
I mean,
what can you,
what can you get to have for $26?
I can get gum,
get two packs of gum.
Actually probably get a lot more than that.
Of course,
if you go to footlocker,
those fucking tee shirts you can get like,
what can you get?
Like,
like 58 tee shirts at foot locker.
Is
that Michael Moore's next movie?
If I was Michael Moore and I was going,
what the fuck should I in the next movie?
Should I make about how poor people are sad and rich people are evil?
I would try and find who are the people who may,
who
are these bubal
[inaudible]
um,
you know,
how do they give you fucking like nine t shirts for $18.
How do they do that?
Um,
you know what,
this,
I'm not even hung over,
but I just,
I rather than being hung over,
which I should have been,
but I wasn't,
but I'm not,
whatever I'm trying to say.
I just woke up with just weird music in my head.
You have to do that.
You wake up,
you drank last night,
you're not hung over,
but he's,
you just wake up and then you just singing some song that you haven't even
thought of for years.
I was just walking around my,
my,
uh,
fucking apartment here,
just walking around and going some like it hot,
some like it hot bump,
bump,
Bapapapapa pap.
Then how it goes,
feel the heat burning into the knife or the night,
whatever the fuck it is is at Robert Palmer.
So I'm like kid hot.
Ooh.
Robert Palmer.
Tell us about your new sexy,
sultry,
single with that hot Latino beat underneath it.
Well,
I had recently gone to Cuba and I are inserted a fucking Cohiba into some
fucking prostitutes,
a or fish.
A dye was just really a overwhelmed by the culture down there and she fucking
hate that.
You know what I mean?
Whenever like the White Star tries to have some sort of ethnic beat under their
music and then they always get to talk about some trip that they took to Swahili
and how when they were sitting there in that Walden resort,
they somehow fucking absorbed the culture.
You know,
you guys have had gone down to the Caribbean,
you're gone down into the Caribbean.
However the fuck you say it.
Some people say Caribbean,
some people say Caribbean,
but to me it's,
it's all one beautiful universe because man down in the Caribbean to go scuba
diving,
to be nose to nose with a fucking Barracuda.
They get barracudas down there quick.
Why don't you look it up and then send me an email and tell me how fucking
uninformed I am.
Actually,
Barracuda are indigenous to the ego of Brazil.
The fuck up.
I can look this shit up to.
What is that a freshwater fish.
You go down to like fucking Uruguay.
Can you get a Barracuda Sandwich?
You know,
just to start your day rather than,
than getting like a bacon,
egg and cheese.
Did they do that and do they use the whole fish?
Because they're better than Americans where we would just like use like just the
best part of the fish.
And then the rest we would just sort of throw out the window,
just toss it back into the ocean and it get all hooked up with like old
rollerblades and fucking,
um,
those shoes.
Every guy war in the late nineties.
Remember those fucking shoes,
those slip on shoes that sort of look like sneakers kind of look like shoes.
Remember those fucking things.
Where are all those right now?
Huh?
I'll tell you where they are.
They're floating out in the middle of the Pacific Ocean,
getting broken down in the sunlight.
Right.
And then some dolphin inhales it and then you go out to Japan.
Right?
And they don't give a fuck about dolphins.
You guys see the cove,
you know,
they'll fucking Dolphin Schindler's list basically.
I couldn't,
I just heard what that movie was about and I fucking love animals so much that I
couldn't eat.
I couldn't even know.
Schindler's list actually had somebody fucking decent in it,
trying to help out those being slaughtered.
I what the fuck am,
I didn't even see the goddamn movie.
All I heard was a bunch of people,
they drive these dolphins into this fucking cove and then they just beat him to
death.
And it was,
uh,
it was so fun just to hear.
It was so fucking sad.
And then it just made me so God damn angry that I was like,
you know what?
I'm not going to fuck.
I'm not gonna.
You know,
I'm not going to watch that stuff is what am I going to do?
Oh,
who got himself to treat at the local Deli?
This is what,
this is how you get out of shape in New York.
Even though you walk around all the time,
as you just walk into a Deli and you're like,
you know what?
I'm going to start my day.
We're on our way to the perfect place,
the perfect place.
[inaudible].
That's another fucking song just popped in my head.
What does that from it step perfect place
was that,
that was like a Hanna Barbera cartoon.
We're on our way to the perfect place.
That perfect place.
Anyways,
I'm sorry.
This is like something I have weird hangovers sometimes I don't have a headache.
I just,
just music pops into my head.
Some like it hot [inaudible] hot Paul Paul,
Paul,
um,
anyways,
some white guy playing yoga blocks.
Does that sound Latino?
Speaking of Latino,
I went into,
well,
one of these little fucking Bodega's
now [inaudible] the s uh,
the fucking orange juicer.
Um,
I was up there and I,
I got myself an Oj and a banana because I'm really into these light breakfast is
now.
I finally realized that when you wake up and you have a lumberjack breakfast at
seriously,
it's like I've been saying on this podcast,
it's like getting up.
It's like if you just woke up the second you woke up and you just sprinted 400
yards without stretching or anything,
didn't even put on your fucking shoes.
He just ran down the street.
I'm on the fucking pebbles,
right?
That's what you're doing to your body.
That's why I started slow.
I get a little fucking corn based orange juice according to food inc all corn
now.
Ooh,
excuse me.
And then I have a banana,
you know,
which is like sort of like a
baby food in a phallic form.
That's why it's like,
it's like a big fucking,
uh,
would have a big yellow dick.
One animal.
I got fucking Porno,
Star Canary if you want to to,
that's what it bananas like.
Right?
So typical New York,
I'm trying to eat healthy and then I look over and I see these two little
toasted balls to add to the fucking,
the,
the canary thing,
right?
Like they lopped off this fucking port nuts.
And I looked at the lady and I was like,
oh,
la,
Santa Rita,
what the fuck are those?
And she's like,
oh,
those are those,
uh,
coconut balls.
And I was like,
get the fuck out of here.
And she says,
I can't get the fuck out of here.
I have to work.
And I said,
Nah,
I didn't mean it.
Literally.
I meant get the fuck Outta here.
Those are made out of coconut.
And she said,
see?
And I was like,
I fucking love coconut,
you know?
And she started laughing like I never said you didn't fuck.
Oh,
do you want them?
And I'm like,
absolutely,
I want them.
So now I have him.
So I have to tell.
And you guys,
I was going to begin my day with a,
you know,
eating really healthy.
I ended up grabbing two sugar balls,
actually.
They're called,
uh,
I actually hear the Coco
Comodo
and underneath an English macaroon coconut.
Here's the ingredients,
sugar,
coconut.
And then in parentheses says,
may contain sodium metaphor,
wholesales,
hush,
hush for whiteness.
I love that shit.
Like how,
how much did they not even research?
What the fuck is?
Yeah,
I might,
it might,
might have a little bit of this Meta by Sulfite for whiteness.
Well,
the coconuts white.
Why would you need to add to that?
Is this some coconut that you fucking had an awareness for?
Years,
egg whites,
invert sugar,
corn Syrup and salt.
So for the most part,
it's all natural except for the sodium.
Metapod bicep vice types of like for whiteness.
And I'm gonna try one.
Let's see.
Sweet dreams are made of the eas.
How bad his fucking Annie Lennox.
When you think of the animals of the fucking baddest rock chicks,
we'll start with white chicks,
right?
We'll move all the way around.
We'll start with the baddest white chicks of all time.
I would say fucking Annie Lennox in no particular order here.
If I was rolling stone,
I do an entire issue of this.
The hundreds greatest rock chicks of all time.
Rolling Stone really is clearly showing people.
If you haven't been paying attention,
how few people buying magazines now?
Oh that fucking listening to discussion.
There's like a donut.
Oh,
it's gross.
Ours too much.
That's fucking disgusting.
I have to take another bite cause now my sugar shot and arise.
All right,
now I'm craving it.
Fuck man.
I need another hit man.
Oh,
oh yeah.
I stand corrected.
These are fucking delicious to eat.
The first bite.
Is your body going?
No,
don't do it.
So it tastes like shit.
Then that sugar gets in your veins and it's like,
come on man.
You know,
you want it,
then you just keep going.
Like this is really rude to be eating on the mic.
All right.
Annie Lennox,
you know,
and that
can't even think now.
Any Linux,
the chick from the pretenders.
Chrissy Hind,
right?
Pat Benatar.
No,
that's not how I want it.
I,
you know,
I always get it confused with the chick from the runaways.
Joan Jett,
Joan jets,
the shit.
Um,
and she's still hot.
Okay.
God Damn it.
Those are fucking delicious.
Oh,
not after a swig of Oj though.
Gross.
Okay.
Yeah.
Really hard to chew.
Okay.
Oh,
what am I fucking neighbors just here.
Just heard that.
Wondering what the fuck I'm talking about?
Um,
all right,
sorry.
Sorry.
You know what?
I'm actually last night.
Um,
no,
finish your fucking talk,
Bill.
If you look at rolling stone,
they used to be this big magazine.
Just I'm talking about when you held it,
it was used to be like a fucking third bigger.
Now they've shrunk it down to,
it's like a third of the size it used to be.
And now every other month they're doing those,
those lists things 100 greatest guitarists of all time,
the 100 greatest tambourine players of all time right now they have the hundred
greatest Beatles songs of all time.
It's like,
did they even write a hundred songs?
You know,
they just do that so people can,
you know,
they,
I guess people always buy those magazines and they go,
well too,
fuck,
oh,
can you put oh hey bulldog in front of,
well my guitar gently weeps and then people write notes.
Was that really worth revisiting?
I don't think it was.
Well those are my top three,
top three fucking white chick rock singers of all time.
And um,
well considering we've been talking so much about Latino's,
let's go with top three Latinos of all time,
Latino's singers.
And this is when my whiteness is going to come to see if I can even
name three.
Uh,
Salina.
They did a movie about her Salina,
Jennifer Lopez and um,
ah,
fuck.
This is embarrassing.
Lucille ball and Lucille Ball.
Fuck you.
She was married to Ricky Ricardo,
Bam.
Those year three,
but she never really sang.
Did she,
what the fuck?
I know.
I know more than that.
Selene.
I don't even know any songs.
Selena was saying.
I just know she had a psycho fan.
That's all I know.
And the Jennifer Lopez plater.
Oh wait,
wait.
The chick from Miami sound machine,
right?
What songs did they sing?
Ooh,
Miami.
We have fucking taken over.
What songs did they sing?
I saw that fucking band stunk.
Miami sound machine,
all that fucking turquoise with all that.
That just die.
When I pictured that my chest was a bunch of people in puffy pants
and they had like 58 people on percussion and then like one keyboard and then
she was skipping around in her boots.
Right?
Isn't that what they're,
what Miami sound machine was the fuck songs do they say,
God damn man,
I used to know all of this shit.
I can't get that.
Robert Palmer Shit out of my head anyways,
whatever.
So I want to learn some,
tell me,
give me your top three Latino fucking singers of all time.
I know somebody who's already compiling a list and getting pissed at me because
I don't know what the fuck I'm talking about.
But that's what people do on this podcast.
Mike,
last week I made a,
I made a reference to the Pullman strike when I was reading about a Grover
Cleveland or some shit like that.
And this guy wrote the roads,
hey,
uninformed bill.
The reason they brought the military in during the Pullman strike was because
the workers in quotes,
he puts,
we're becoming violent.
Not because they were striking because they were attacking the alternate workers
brought in to fill the void of labour caused by this strike.
And this is hilarious.
The guy writes down his name,
marketing and business development coordinator.
Yet you sound like the guy who would side with the fucking people who,
who are underpaying.
It's first of all,
why do you put workers in,
in,
uh,
in parentheses?
You know what I mean?
The strike was because the workers were becoming violent,
not because they were striking,
because they were attacking the,
the scabs they brought into to take their jobs.
That's part of a strike.
You dumb fuck.
You know,
and you know,
I love to sir,
is the way you're acting as though you had even heard of the Pullman strike
before I said it.
That's that classic Internet Shit where you don't have to go to the library
anymore.
He just look up the Pullman strike and then you read two paragraphs and then
you're like,
oh,
actually,
you know what the reason is you're just as dumb as me,
sir.
Of course,
they attack the scab workers brought in because now they're going to be out of
out of a job.
And that was my point.
And who does the military side with the military works for the fucking rich
people.
All right.
If you don't fucking believe that,
that I'm not going to eat another fucking coconut ball.
Oh,
it just gets better.
No,
it doesn't.
All right,
that's enough of that.
Jesus Christ.
Jesus.
All right,
let's talk NFL football.
Everybody.
Oh,
but before I do the [inaudible],
podcast.com,
everybody,
um,
I made a video on there,
where I did a little tour of the comedy store and Elsa stood outside the comedy
store and they talk shit about some of the people walking by down the street.
If you guys want to check it out,
go to the MLM,
podcast.com.
Um,
the official,
the one and only the only one there is the official fan page of the Monday
morning podcast.
And I also want to thank everybody who went out and bought the old GV ringtone
last week.
All right.
I uh,
was very impressed with the amount of people that,
uh,
that that went ahead and bought the a ringtone if he didn't listen last week.
I have a new ring tone at all costs is 99 cents.
And um,
you know,
that way I don't have to really charge for the fucking podcast and it's also a,
um,
it's not required if you want to do what you can.
If you don't,
you don't,
it's no big deal.
And uh,
we have all the instructions up there.
If you have an iPhone,
it goes right onto your phone.
If you have a blackberry,
there's like one little thing you have to do with something,
but they have all the instructions on the m podcast on how to upload it to your
phone.
And um,
you know,
we just want to thank everybody for being patient,
uh,
for a couple,
took a couple of days to explain it to,
to get the information out there.
So I wanted to thank you guys for chipping and seriously means a lot to me that
people actually went out and supported the podcasts like that.
So thank you from the bottom of my heart.
And the gentleman who runs the MM podcast.com.
All right.
And with that
Bop,
bop,
it's time to talk about NFL football here.
Um,
I actually was flying on a plane during the Patriots game,
so I can't really talk too much about it.
Other than that,
I just,
I was watching,
I actually had satellite TV on,
on the,
on the plane,
so I was sitting there going,
Oh fuck,
I'm gonna miss the fucking game.
And then I see that they're going to have satellite TV.
And I got excited all boy.
Oh boy.
Right.
And I fucking turn it on and all I get,
I had NBC
and then the rest were like discovery animal planet.
And then they had three ESPNs.
Okay.
So I'm praying how I hope and pray that I will,
but today I am still just a bill.
Um,
fuck you.
The songs are in my head because I'm hung over.
I'm praying that the Patriots game was going to be on NBC.
And it turned out that not only was the game not on NBC,
they didn't even have a football game on NBC.
They had some fucking infomercial on insults.
So I was like,
you gotta be fucking kidding me.
Right?
You gotta be fucking kidding me.
And uh,
so then I,
I just was watching ESPN.
I was watching all the college football games that I already watched.
Uh,
I think Michigan's back,
everybody
hail to the victors value yet hell to the victor
[inaudible]
bap,
bap.
Bap,
bap,
bap.
So
you want to just sit there?
I did three fucking college songs and they all sound the exact fucking same hail
to the victors.
Wake up the echoes and fucking uh,
the Fleetwood Mac Trojan band.
It's all all the same shit.
Anyways.
Yeah.
So I watched that and I watched the uh,
the USA basketball game against a Turkey.
That was the shit.
And uh,
we won that championship.
But anyways,
I was watching the ticker and by the way,
what's his face there is going to be the next superstar.
And I saw him when he played in Seattle and I can't even remember his fucking
name already cause I'm that fucking hung over.
Come on brain work for me
because with a d,
I can't fucking remember,
but he was the shit he was hitting.
Fall away.
Three pointers as a six,
10.
I even know what position you play.
I don't know.
I don't know shit about basketball.
All right,
let's plow ahead here.
Um,
patriots won.
The cults lost,
so I'm excited,
right?
I'm so,
so excited.
How about Detroit?
How about Cleveland?
Come on.
You guys,
you've got admit,
you know,
you had a little bit,
uh,
I think,
I think that does this,
uh,
a ray of light.
I didn't see any either one of those fucking games,
but I was just,
I was just watching the ticker and um,
I saw that that dude from outplay for cal best tattoo touchdowns,
right.
And Cleveland was basically one in the fucking game right down to the end.
I know I'm not trying to talk down to you guys,
but I'm just saying,
you know,
whenever you beat Miami,
that's got to feel good luck.
You know,
it's the main reason why I'm bringing this shit up is,
is because I want to say this shit before the fucking game comes out tonight.
I got 50 bucks on the ravens tonight.
Straight up.
I bet it's straight up.
Even though the jets are favored by like six.
I don't know what the line is,
but I was like,
you know what?
You can keep your fucking points there,
missy.
I don't give a shit.
That's how confident I am.
How fucking dumb are the New York jets?
What do they,
can you just,
can somebody explain to me the strategy of pissing off every fucking every team
in the league?
It's first of all,
I love it being a patriots fan because for the first time in 10 fucking years
nobody was talking
about bill Belicheck.
Nobody was talking about the Patriots.
Nobody was talking about Tom Brady.
Really?
The guy even got into a fucking car accident and that was barely a fucking story
compared to the shit storm
that is going on with the New York jets.
What?
What are they doing?
Let me ask you guys a question.
How amped up does Ray Lewis get before a football game when,
when the other team hasn't talked shit about them?
Are they out there out of their fucking minds?
Ray Lewis,
I put it on my Facebook page.
That's my prediction.
He is going to rip Sanchez his fucking head off tonight.
Sanchez.
This guy who everybody for some reason they're forgetting
the up and down season that he had last year and they're,
they're acting like they have this proven quarterback.
I don't get it man.
And they went out and they drafted all,
they got signed,
all these free agents,
they're really reminded me of the University of Miami when they got off the
plane wearing the fatigues and they were talking all this shit.
And then when it came down to it,
they didn't fucking win anything.
Remember that?
Well,
like the,
the Los Angeles Lakers,
when they added Gary Payton and Karl Malone,
and you're thinking,
how can they not fucking,
and then they didn't,
I don't,
I don't get it that that year when the Patriots went undefeated in the regular
season and then get their asses kicked in in the super bowl by the giants,
it's like the hype was so fucking big that from November on,
we were playing playoff games.
Teams were coming in
so fucking amped up to kick the shit out of us.
It just wore it.
It wore us down.
It was down to me while no one's paying attention to the giants,
to the point that Jane has put up like 35 points and the last week of the season
against us.
And for some reason we were still 14 point favorites three fucking weeks later
to this day,
I kicked myself for not taking that bet.
And uh,
yeah,
it was ridiculous.
I mean,
while the giants had beaten Tampa Bay in Tampa Bay,
they beat Dallas in Dallas.
They beat Green Bay and Green Bay and no one's paying attention to them.
Then everybody sat there with the jaws on the ground.
They kicked him,
didn't even kick the shit out of us.
They just beat us like,
holy fuck.
How did this team that beat three awesome teams and their own fucking building
come in and beat us is fucking ridiculous.
So the jets have started their season at zero and zero with the whole league as
amped up the kick the shit out of them as people were amped up to beat the
fucking patriots.
It by mid November.
All right,
and I'm telling you right now,
they are going to have a mediocre fucking season.
I think it's going to start off with the loss tonight.
I'm not saying that they're not going to go nine and seven,
but these guys,
I don't know what the fucking problem is and not to mention that now they have a
nice little scandal here.
Cover the daily news.
They says,
cool.
Your jets,
TV reporter,
flags team for Lewd behavior.
Um,
Ian is saints reporter for as TV.
Where the fuck is that broadcast?
It's is at the center of a jet Brouhaha.
Basically,
if you see this girl,
she's fucking hottie right?
She's got her little pass here.
And uh,
you know,
she's got some Cleveland show.
Oh my God.
Are you serious?
They got a picture of her edit jets practice.
She's got on the tightest fucking jeans I've ever seen in my life with the most
perfect round ass you've ever seen.
And she's in high heels.
Okay.
And she's walking around a bunch of football players who got that testosterone
going with a fat shit-talking coach.
Let me guess.
Somebody said something out of line.
Oh,
this is just,
this is,
you know what I mean?
This right here.
And this is one of these things where you can't say,
we'll look how you're dressed cause they go,
you're playing the victim.
She should have a right to have three quarters ever tits outside of her shirt
with a thong going up her fucking ass crack.
And she should be allowed to walk into a locker room with a bunch of football
players and not have one out of fucking whatever the fuck are you going to say?
Well,
one fucking rude comic.
Give me a break.
Nfl boss Roger Goodell was demanding answers last night from jets players.
Well,
why don't you look at the pictures,
Roger.
Huh?
What are you a fucking unit?
You don't understand what the problem was.
Uh,
for players,
coaches accused of subjecting of female sports reporter to sexist locker room
conduct.
They should've just said for subjecting her to lock a room conduct.
This is basically what happened.
She went into a locker room and was subjected to locker room conduct.
Can you believe it?
I remember last night when I went out to a bar and I was subjected to barroom
conduct.
I couldn't believe it.
I was like,
what am I in a bar or something as they prepare for their season opener tonight,
gang green is dealing with the burgeoning scandal over the treatment of Inez
Saints,
uh,
for Azteca of Mexico.
This girl is a 10.
She's fucking smoking gorgeous Emmy.
You got to see the way she's dressed.
Okay.
And Fuck you ladies.
Fuck you.
Look at the way she's dressed.
She's one of those,
you know what's funny about the broads out there?
It is.
This is the kind of girl,
right?
The kind of woman that kind of fucking who,
uh,
who,
if you know any of these women,
you know,
we'll listen to his podcast.
They walking down the street with their husband and this girl comes walking by,
they immediately,
they date fucking,
you know,
in the eyes become like little slits.
Is He looking at me?
You know,
and then they're looking at their husband and they're going to get mad at you
because this other bitch goes to the gym.
You know,
like somehow it's your fucking fault and they fucking looking at you because
they can't just come out and say,
oh my God,
that girl is fucking gorgeous.
I'm so jealous her,
they,
they can't,
they can't own that emotion.
So then they look at you and they're just waiting for you to glance in that pert
and that woman's direction so they can blame you that this fuck another girl is
eaten,
right?
And,
and fucking doing herself up.
Right?
It's going to become your fucking fault.
I used to do a bit about that.
Next time you,
you know,
here's one for you guys to burn a joke right here that I never fucking recorded.
So who gives a shit next time you walking down the street with your girlfriend,
right in this fucking unbelievably smoking check comes walking up the street,
right?
And what do you got?
And she immediately just looks at you like,
go ahead and look at her so I can take out my fucking hatred of this better
looking girl and make it your fucking fault,
right?
This is what you do.
Rather than trying to look away and having blood come out out of your eyes.
You try not to look at this fucking hot peas.
Hey,
it's coming up the street.
What you do is you fucking point right at her and whatever she's wearing,
you tell your girl that she'd look great in that you point right.
And I'd be like,
you know what?
You'd look great in a dress like that.
Right?
And then immediately just a p,
you know,
it makes her insecurity go,
oh my God.
Really?
Do you think I could get away with wearing something?
They totally huge girls failing.
Good.
You're staring at the girl's ass.
You're talking about the cut of the dress.
It's bullshit.
You're checking around without disrespecting your woman.
See right there.
Bill Burke bringing couples together.
All right,
let's continue on here.
Um,
so this woman,
32 years old,
still in smoke and fucking shape of former Miss Universe contestant complaints,
she was bombarded with cat calls and boarish antiques at the jets,
New Jersey training facility to the extent she wanted to.
And in quotes that cover my ears.
I'm dying of embarrassment.
Yeah.
This woman,
right?
Former Miss Universe contestant who would walk on stage with a fucking string
bikini and high heels with the hoo ha hanging out talking about how to save
Greenland or whatever is embarrassed cause she walked around.
I mean give me a,
you know what I mean?
This is why women stink.
It's like,
what are you doing there to begin with?
It's a bunch of guys playing football can,
it's like,
and then we're cool enough to let you in there and then everybody has to fucking
adjust their behavior because your there waig scares me.
Scares me.
There's a lady present.
You know what I mean?
And You wonder why you get called a cunt.
That's why.
Right fucking there.
It's just fucking unbelievable.
I would never walk into a Goddamn baby shower be,
oh,
excuse me.
Excuse me.
There's a guy president,
can we put a fucking game on Ovia I wouldn't.
I'd be standing in the and going,
oh Geez,
when is this Shit gonna be over?
But I wouldn't at any point try to cock block what anybody was fucking talking
about.
Go ahead and talk about sex in the city.
Talk about your favorite shoes or whatever the fuck it is you do.
I wouldn't be covering my ears.
Dying of embarrassment.
If you all started talking about my package,
I'd be flattered.
Okay.
Um,
this is some of the more ignorant shit that I've sat on this podcast,
but I think there's a point behind this.
Let's continue with the article.
MMM.
Goodell is she said,
I'm dying of embarrassment.
Saints tweeted in Spanish,
um,
Goodell immediately ordered an investigation into the troubling in air quotes,
allegations,
which were addressed in a team meeting last night.
Uh,
there's meeting is now called to order,
uh,
last night when that smoking hot chick with the tight clothes came in and
everybody said,
God Damn,
look at that fucking ass.
Yeah.
You're not allowed to do that anymore.
Uh,
excuse me,
coach.
Ah,
yeah.
Yes sir.
Yeah.
Well,
you're talking about that girl who came in and her titties way hanging out of
her shirt.
Yeah,
that one.
We are disrespected her.
See,
this is,
this is the deal.
All right.
They come down,
they want the fucking attention.
You know what?
Wait,
what is she,
what is she doing in the fucking locker room to begin with?
You know?
Well,
she even in the locker room,
did I even,
they even say that.
I can't remember.
Didn't you see any given Sunday?
You don't remember that movie?
You're going to stand there and there's gonna be some black dude with a dick
down to the floor.
I mean,
why are you going in?
I wouldn't go in there if I went in there,
they'd start giving me cat calls.
Like I was that fresh fish guy when the beginning of shots,
Shawshank redemption,
and I'd be dying of embarrassment too,
but I'd fucking take it.
It'd be like,
ah,
well what the fuck did you think was going to happen?
You're a fucking Pansy and you come walking into an NFL locker room,
they're all going to give you shit and say you're a pussy,
right?
I mean,
what kind of a fucking world are we living in now?
When a gorgeous woman wearing tight,
ridiculous clothes is going to walk into a fucking at a football practice and
she's going to get upset that she got unwanted attention.
Well,
why don't you come there and dress like they did in the 18 hundreds with one of
the big hoop skirts so they can't see you fucking thighs.
This chick is fucking ridiculous.
Look,
look at the New York Daily News and look at the little inset picture that they
have of her.
I'm sure they did it for a fucking reason.
It's ridiculous.
Look at that fucking ass.
Look at it.
That's the first thing I think.
Look at that fucking ass.
Jesus Christ.
And then she's holding a Mike looks like a dick in her hand while she bobbing
her head up and down and she asked the questions.
This is like entrapment.
Okay.
Anyways,
let's fucking continue.
Um,
but Papa,
Papa,
we've had contact with the team multiple times and are moving very aggressively
to establish the facts.
The NFL spokesman Greg,
I Hilo said jets owner woody Johnson woke up from his coma and said,
oh,
wait,
that guy,
that guy's actually young,
uh,
called saints to hear his side of the story,
said that,
that the team will take any appropriate steps necessary to maintain a respectful
environment for the media.
Basically,
this girl is now going to become a fucking millionaire off of this lawsuit
because she walked to an NFL practice were there miss universe body with tight
fucking clothes on?
And somebody said,
God Damn,
look at that fucking ass right there.
Hey mark,
what the fuck would you do with dad?
Right?
I'd fucking Ben Rover fucking table
and then fucking rex Ryan.
I can't even see in my fucking my fucking stomach.
So big.
Huh?
Was that a good one?
Players.
Do you guys like me?
I talk just like you.
I can't wait for them to fucking lose tonight.
They're going to get their fucking asses kicked and that can get their asses
kicked,
but they're going to lose.
They're going to lose them then they're going to have a short week.
All right,
and guess who's back the New England patriots?
Huh?
38 fucking points up against.
Oh,
Sinco Terrell Owens.
Kate Mckinnon.
What's the name of your quarterback?
Something.
Wilson.
I don't even know the name of your fucking quarterback.
He was awesome.
And then he got hurt.
He's actually a good quarterback with the fuck's his name.
I know it's not caving now.
Ucla fucking Heisman trophy winner.
Classic Chicago Bear quarterback drug draft.
They love Kate Mcdowell and they loved the Rex Grossman for some reason they
didn't like Doug Flutie.
Let's keep,
let's ship him out of there.
Really,
you want to ship a proven winner out?
Absolutely.
We don't want him around here leading the team to victories.
Where the fuck is that under the Goddamn patriots game here?
Oh,
Carson Palmer.
This is what I love about that man.
He was 34 for 50 for 345 yards.
Oh,
chose Sinco had 12 catches for 159 yards.
All right.
Yet they only scored 24 fucking points.
You know my buddy was saying it,
they,
they getting back to that bend but don't break.
You know,
someone else was telling me Belicheck is doing the defense again,
which is his fucking,
that's,
that's what he does.
I don't know.
I have a,
I have high hopes,
but you know it's not about the patriots this year.
It's all about the JTS jets,
jets,
jets.
Right.
Run in their fucking yaps.
You wanted the attention now you got it.
Ah,
I can't fucking wait.
Do you guys looked up the stats of that fucking Joe Flacco,
Joe Falco,
whatever the fuck his name is.
I didn't know what his name is.
All I know is they raped us last year in the playoffs.
You got ray rice is going to be running all over you fucking cunts.
Huh?
What do you think?
Cause you got that old guy from the dolphins,
that good looking son of a bitch.
You should be doing fucking underwear ads like Jim Palmer.
That's the guy.
That's the guy that's going to stop everybody.
That dude has been shown up late to practice.
Rex Ryan is making a joke out of it because he has such a fucking need to be
liked by his own goddamn players.
You wait,
you wait to the fucking wheels fall off.
All right,
here's,
here's a contest I want.
I want to introduce here.
How about
whoever guesses which week?
Rex Ryan's going to fucking cry first after which game.
If you pick it right,
I'm going to send you an autographed copy of my new fucking DVD.
So there you go.
People,
he got fucking 17 weeks to pick when actually not this week,
16 weeks.
I'm including the bye week.
The first week he's going to start fucking crying because somebody criticized,
you know,
or somebody stole his m and m flavored fucking ice cream.
All right.
Enough of this shit.
That's my thing.
I got 50 bucks,
50 bucks in the Ravens and I'm confident.
I'm confident that not only I didn't even take the spread straight up.
Can you tell,
I don't know what else to talk about.
I just keep saying over and over again what my bet is.
Let's talk about depression.
Shall We?
Speaking of fucking Rex Ryan,
um,
somebody sent me a long email here that should eat up some time.
Um,
I actually did,
I tell you guys last night,
we actually recorded me.
Andrew Rosa got fucking hammered last night and we like,
you know,
we should do,
we should go home and record a drunk,
uninformed.
I'm like,
well I have to do the Monday morning podcast.
He goes,
we'll fucking do that too.
So last night for an hour in a half as we sat there drinking and getting even
more drunk,
drunk,
[inaudible],
whatever the fucking word is,
we recorded,
we talked for at least an hour and a half.
The recorder shut off at an hour and 15 fucking minutes and you just hear us get
progressively more and more drunk.
Uh,
I listened to it.
There's a lot of funny moments,
but it's just way too long.
So I am going to,
I'm going to edit it,
I'm going to dice it up and I'll,
I'll,
I'll put together a greatest hits of it.
They got that coming up,
but I just,
it was just too much self sabotage.
It's like I got my special coming out this week.
I really had to make sure I hyped it and I completely was not hyping it in a,
in a great way.
Uh,
you know,
it was just thought it was bad,
it was bad and there was a lot of embarrassing moments and you know,
I,
you know,
I'm just,
I'm going to edit it people,
that's what I'm trying to say.
All right,
go fuck yourself and not putting it all up.
All right.
Youtube videos of the week.
A fat kid goes insane after getting air horned in the face.
Try to guess what that one's about.
Fat Kid goes insane after getting air horned air horn in the face and uh,
this kid,
his face,
he looks like,
if,
if precious was a white eight year old,
just picture that face.
That's what this kid looks like.
All right,
here's what I'm sure everybody saw.
It says face verse watermelon.
This is somebody on the amazing race that took a slingshot and,
and shot a watermelon on a fucking cantaloupe.
I don't know what it was.
And it came back and bless her right in the face.
It's absolutely hilarious.
They
actually showed it on ESPN.
They did the top 10 funny sports moments of the weakened.
Hers was number one.
And you know what they did because she's abroad.
What they had to do was they put,
you know,
you know when they had the list of shit that they're going to talk about coming
up on the right hand part of the screen out of nowhere,
right before the cantaloupe or watermelon blasts or in the face,
they put that up and half censored her head.
Cause I can guarantee you there was some woman there going,
this is going to Jeff,
it's going to um,
cause violence against women.
How is it going to cause violence against women?
Because the way the watermelon just slaps her in the face,
it's just it,
it was self inflicted.
That's one of those things,
once again,
those double standard,
if a guy did that,
do you think they'd censor it?
What if it came back and hit him in his nuts and he actually lost the ability to
have a child?
They still would've shown that completely uncensored.
Wait a minute.
Is this a special guests who just walked in?
Joe,
I got like an,
I've got another eight minutes.
Just sit down and help me throw it.
Oh,
don't be a fag.
Get over here to pick up the microphone.
Ladies and gentlemen.
Look who just walked in.
Hey folks,
Joe to Rosa.
Or are you Jesus Christ.
Joe,
what are you doing here?
I uh,
you know,
I was just walking through the studio bill or the,
I saw you through the glass.
This is like that moment when fucking Johnny Carson walked over to,
uh,
what's his face?
His Sitcom when he was doing CPO.
Sharkey remember that when he broke his,
uh,
what's his name?
Dom.
Dom Delouis.
Don Rickles.
Yeah.
He just came walking in.
This is very old school.
Yeah.
I just actually alluded to them.
Uh,
and not even alluded.
I mentioned that we did a podcast.
I finally did talk to how we did a podcast last night.
Completely fucking shit faced and a of the hour and 14 minutes.
How much do you think is going to be funny that we can actually chop up?
I think at least four minutes of it was really good.
I think the bulk of it was funny,
which was actually a good point about like it's just a little too much all at
once.
Like you got to split it up a little bit and it just kept me and then by the end
I was just,
I was really getting into your financial businesses of some deal that you had
and we were like,
yeah,
we don't,
we don't want that on there.
Yeah,
yeah.
Let me tell you about the cons and that's business gel.
It was really sloppy.
But dude,
I got to tell you a fucking hilarious on it you to,
I loved it.
I loved,
I was little.
I was,
I was kind of an angry let's that whiskey shit to bear.
I'm a happy drunk,
you know,
don't blame them.
Don't blame the whiskey bill.
Oh No,
no.
I'm already angry.
But like when I'm,
when I'm fucking,
when I'm sober,
I keep,
I keep it in check for the most part,
for the most part.
But when I drink whiskey,
then I'm not,
if I drink beer,
you know,
I got my arm around people and we'll all go down together.
We're all singing songs.
Right?
I'm good time Charlie with the beer.
I start drinking whiskey.
Ah,
it's awful.
Do,
can you finish chewing whatever's in your mouth to fingernails biting my nails?
I ah,
through the doors.
He's checking.
No,
I'm sorry.
What?
Do you want to spit it out?
Or You,
you yelled at me to get over here and sit down.
Yeah.
What do you want me to do?
I want you to fucking
see what happens.
Why?
Why Joe?
Yeah.
Be a professional.
You know,
Joe,
you look at this,
you know,
I was just,
and I just went off on this.
Can you see this woman here?
She walked,
she showed up at a,
at a NFL practice.
This former Miss Universe here.
Look out.
She dressed at the practice.
Oh yeah.
Looking good.
She's hot.
Well,
what?
Yeah,
and guess,
and evidently somebody made some people made,
she was subjected to catcalling.
Joe,
can you imagine that?
You could look like that,
dress like that.
And you can't go to an NFL practice without getting cashflow.
She upset about it.
Upset.
She tweeted in Spanish that she was,
um,
dying of embarrassment.
She had to cover her ears.
Well,
look,
I gotta say though,
she looks great,
but she is wearing jeans and a shirt.
It's like,
what the hell she supposed to wear?
Does that when she's in a miniskirt.
Okay,
Joe,
she's wearing high heels.
Look at a Gel.
How tight are those goddamn jeans?
Ah,
righteously tay.
Really?
Joe,
what would you do with that Joe?
Ah,
Bill.
Tell me fucking
leave it in disappointment.
Look,
I'm not looking,
I'm not condoning that.
You shouldn't,
you shouldn't do that.
Hey,
she was asking for it.
I'm not,
I'm not.
She was so,
she is kind of a Jesus.
What the hell is she supposed to wear?
What she's supposed to wear?
Sweatpants.
Joe,
is it possible for those genes to get any tighter?
No,
but that's how chicks wear their jeans.
Chicks don't wear baggy jeans.
They were tight jeans.
Like,
you know something,
Joe,
why don't you just walk back out the door and bring in the fucking Joe Derosa
that I know.
All right.
All right,
Joe.
He's a no show their work.
I'm kidding.
What Joseph?
If I walk through central park at three in the fucking morning dress like
Liberace,
sing an almond,
the money,
and I get the shit kicked out of me and I get mugged.
It's wrong.
I should be able to do that.
But do I have any sort of fucking personal responsibility for my own fucking
safety?
All right.
You don't want go to a football practice.
She's got high heeled shoes.
She,
you know what?
First thing that drops a girls sex sex thing is down by at least 30% is when
they wear those flats.
Isn't that the worst?
When you,
when you're in a relationship and they get so comfortable that they stopped
jacking their ass up.
Yeah,
and they just wear the flats and all of a sudden they look like,
like they're a little clown climbing out of a car.
Yeah.
She should have worn those.
You're doing,
you're preaching to the choir.
I,
I'm doing a bit of doing my bit a bit in my act right now about take your
lashes,
like you chose this role and the the soul,
why are you defending this girl?
I'm saying,
I'm,
I'm you,
you convert,
you convinced me the center,
the center piece of the bid is that,
uh,
it's about this fat girl cock blocking me with the skinny girl and doing the
whole angry fat girl thing.
And it's like,
yeah.
It's just like,
you know,
I didn't eat all the egg sandwiches you did.
That was your decision.
You're going to get mad at me that I'm not leap frogging over your hot friend to
get a shout at your Michelin Man Body right now.
There's nothing wrong with it.
You Fat.
That's okay.
But take the fucking hit sometimes.
You know what I mean?
It's not fair to everybody else.
You're waltzing around like you're a piece of Taylor.
You're not,
you know?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
He's sitting there like a walrus.
Sunning yourself at the bar.
Yeah.
But my whole thing too is like,
you know,
I'm part Arab.
If I were a turban on an airplane,
I gotta be ready for a couple of people to be like,
Ooh,
fuck is going on over.
You know,
like I told them [inaudible] territory,
dude.
She is.
Look,
I'm not saying that she's a bad person.
She looks like she's fucking gorgeous,
but she doesn't,
she doesn't look like I look at her.
I was at the shirt she was wearing.
That's the,
this is,
that's well that's her at the Superbowl.
But is that the shot?
The shot you showed me in the,
in the actual article was the ass shot,
is that what she looked like from the front?
That is her.
I mean that's not her at the practice,
but yeah,
that's what she wearing.
She's wearing that nightclub top.
She's got like the diamonds on the tits.
Tits.
Yeah.
Glittery tit shirt.
It's ridiculous.
Glittery Ted.
I mean,
look,
yeah,
you can't,
you got to understand that.
Ooh,
she sweet.
This is what pisses me off,
Joe,
is it's NFL football.
It's a guy sport.
There's a bunch of guys playing it.
Nobody asked you to fucking come there.
You inserted yourself into this situation and this,
this,
I'm repeating myself in the podcast,
but just to hear your opinion,
that's when,
don't you hate that when if much guys hanging out,
you shooting the shit and we're talking,
then I'll send you just said,
it scares me.
Ski.
There's a lady present and then all the fun just stops and everybody has to
adjust their fucking behavior because you're there.
You know,
my favorite thing ever been on chest,
let me hear some hate hate is when,
uh,
like a waitress will say that to a bunch of drunk guys and there's always the
one 50,
you know,
the waitress will go like,
uh,
is that how you talk in front of a lady?
And then there's always one 50 year old drug that goes,
well,
why don't you show me a fucking lady?
And I'll tell Ya,
you know,
it's such an old joke,
but it always gets a laugh.
It always gets a laugh.
It's just nothing.
Ah,
you know,
somebody was telling me,
um,
I,
when I was,
I was out in Denver,
they were saying,
um,
that they will,
they went out to go shoot pool right there shooting.
Now I remember they were shooting pool and there was a,
you know,
they,
they were kicking the shit out of these guys and there was this group of guys
they had next,
right?
And then some girl Cottey comes up and she didn't want to fucking wait and she
puts her money down,
but she so fucking hot that these other ball is jackasses.
They let her cut right night and then she's making this big,
and then she's just such a already,
just an arrogant fucking twat that these guys are like,
look,
we don't want to play.
We don't want to play.
You were going to play those guys.
Right?
And she gets blah,
blah,
giving him shit.
And he goes,
look,
we're not playing.
You were playing those guys and she took a full drink and throw it in this guide
.
Oof.
So I go,
well,
you can't hit them.
What do you do?
He goes,
Oh,
this guy's brilliant.
He,
he's a spitter.
He doesn't,
he just,
when she goes and he was so fucking much,
what are you going to do?
Are you going to hit me?
He goes,
no,
I'm not going to hit you.
And he goes,
hit her right in the chest and it rolled down between her titties.
And this is the worst part.
The bouncers come over,
flipping the end.
They fucking of course go.
And those guys who she cut all fucking ran at,
at,
at they do to just did that shit.
Oh,
that's great.
Just immediately.
It's fucking,
yeah,
because spitting on somebody is so much worse.
I'd much rather get blasted into it.
I even take the brain damage.
Did you ever hear that term or that Tony Roberts joke where he's like,
he's like fucked up to hit a woman.
I would never hit.
All right.
I'm bullshit.
Okay.
And he's like,
if you put your hands on me,
I'll fucking lay out.
Oh,
that's awesome stuff.
I could hit me fine.
Don't do this whole bit.
Go See Tony Robertson.
Oh wait,
I gotta finish this bit.
It's so funny,
Dude.
He goes,
you see those commercials?
Are you guys every 12 seconds a woman is hit [inaudible] in this country?
And he goes,
he goes,
they will tell you how every eight seconds there's a bitch in your face.
Go ahead.
How about that?
My bad,
my bad.
And he goes,
I've warned you,
bitch you at four seconds.
Tony Robbins,
one of the most underrated comedians of all time.
That guy is so fucking ridiculously talented.
He's so funny.
Yeah,
I saw them on comedy central.
Typical,
ridiculously talented duties.
Unbelievably humble.
I saw him on comedy central and he,
I think he just starts the bit like this.
He just goes and it was so good.
Cause I fucking hate Wendy Williams.
He goes,
Wendy Williams and Danny Glover or the same mother fucking person.
That's so mean.
All right,
well we've got to wrap up the podcast here.
Joe,
with his squeaky little voice.
That really just annoyed me.
Oh yeah,
it's Yo me.
Oh,
oh,
here's another youtube video to watch.
Uh,
go to [inaudible] dot com uh,
build dances.
Classic bloopers.
Joe,
I actually have to show you this one.
This is like a guy trying to do a fishing show and one of them,
I swear to God,
I can't believe that it's actually true.
He's going down the river and in the distance,
the other camera man from the two,
they're doing like a two shot the chute,
right?
The other camera man,
first of all is in the shot and he's edging towards the,
the bank to get a better shop and it's an eight foot drop into the revenue from
that guy with the falls into the fucking river
and the,
what's his face?
He's one of those redneck guys who he gets mad,
but he's like a,
a classic dude so he doesn't curse.
So he uses like those redneck Hicks.
I don't know what the fuck they are,
but he's,
is that dagnabbit you know two goes in the water.
I'm butchering it.
It's actually,
it's fucking hilarious.
Hey,
I gotta hop in the shower cause Bobby Kelly's meeting me here in a couple of
these Joe,
but Bobby Kelly,
is he gonna come walking through the door?
No,
he's going to ring the buzzer and I got to rally so I gotta get ready here.
So lazy boy chairs,
we,
no,
it's my show.
I tell you when we're,
when we were up against the heartbreak and it's time you to go,
where are you going Joe?
You're just going to put it down.
It is going to tap out and walk out.
I get shower.
Jesus.
All right,
no problem.
Joe.
To rose,
everybody.
Jode Rosie has a new CD out that I would have hiked,
but he walked away.
We'll give me the height.
What's the hype,
Joe?
When does it come out now?
Seriously,
Joel,
if it was out,
people will be talking about it.
When does it come out?
Oh Jesus,
it's out.
It's called out the depression auction and I endorse it.
Joe Rock.
Come on.
He did want he or eat burned a bit on the podcast for you.
Why am I yelling?
Um,
anyways,
uh,
I think that's going to be the podcast for this week.
I'm doing a ton of media this week.
Fans of the Opie and Anthony Program.
I believe I'm going to be on there.
Uh,
definitely tomorrow.
Hopefully Wednesday.
I'm basically going to be on that show as many days as they'll have me because,
uh,
I like those sons of bitches.
Um,
that's it.
No,
seriously.
And if you don't listen to the OPR Anthony Program,
I don't know what your problem is.
Get an XM satellite,
whatever the Fuck Sirius XM player,
and check those guys out.
Watch a little bit of this stuff on Youtube.
They're uh,
they're,
they're fucking awesome.
So I'm going to be doing them this week.
I'll probably be doing something on versus,
and um,
you know what,
as I do them,
if they're not live and they're going to be shown later,
I'll just on the MM podcast,
we'll have that information up there.
But if you didn't get the,
Oh gee,
she's ringtone.
You can go to the [inaudible] podcast.com and on the left hand corner you'll see
it right there.
And you just click on old Jesus and you can get it,
put it in your phone.
And then whenever the biggest continue life calls you up,
that's what your phone's going to be saying.
Oh Gee,
go.
Um,
if you don't,
don't do it.
I don't give a fuck.
I'm just happy you listening.
All right.
You guys have a great week and a that's my prediction.
Ravens will win.
Um,
and I don't know,
jets,
jets are patriots.
I gotta be honest with you.
Could go either direction,
but I'm really liking what I watched on the ticker tape on the airplane.
I have no fucking idea.
I miss,
I don't,
I can't judge the Patriots,
but uh,
and I think the jets are going to at best Miko tenants six after all that
fucking Yip Yapping,
they'll probably make it into the playoffs.
God knows they got in,
they got enough talent on the fucking team,
but I think all this shit talking is really gonna hurt them and I don't,
I don't think they're going to go as far as they went last year.
What do you think about that?
Huh?
Jets play like a jet.
What the fuck does that mean?
You haven't won one since 1969 what does that mean?
Get your fans all excited and then you shit the bed in January.
What Joe?
That's what they do,
Joe.
They haven't won since.
We were excited that we landed on the moon like that was going to lead to new
real estate.
That was the last time they want Joe.
I was six months old.
Joe,
six months old.
Curt Gowdy announced the last time that they want a bowl.
All right.
Jim Morrison was still alive.
Joe,
Jimi Hendrix was still putting out albums.
Joe De Rosa the last time they won and this same play like a jet.
When you're a jet,
you're a jet all the way.
I like that.
Oh,
that's from a west side story.
That really is where we differ.
You're talking about the jets that I'm singing the song.
That sounds like one of the old stair really into that old school shit.
You know what the sad thing about the jet side?
They're the only professional franchise and all four sports that actually sub
lets their stadium let's,
yeah.
If they play a giant stadium there.
You know what they are?
They're like that fucking loser who never moves out.
And that window of getting married and actually meeting somebody just closes and
then they just say fuck it.
And they're just waiting for the last of their alive parent to die so that they
can take,
they can take over the house.
Oh God.
It never ends his podcast when he's at your apartment.
Oh Jesus.
Joe,
look at you.
Come with a little bit of anger.
Joe.
You know what I hate are uninsured.
Unashamed.
You are about your torso.
I give Joe Shit because his body,
he looks like an adolescent.
Will Ferrell like what picture will Ferrel's body at 23
do you,
have you ever done a pull up in your life?
Do you like,
do you even have those muscles?
Yeah,
he left me.
I was really going to compare him to like the Camaro rally sport.
You know somebody goes out and you get the Iraq,
right?
You got the air conditioner,
you got the tee tops,
you get the electric windows,
and then you had the rally sport,
which you basically had the same body,
but you didn't have those options.
I was going to go that route.
Is that what you were going to do,
Bill?
Where are you going to do it?
In a funny way because the way you presented that,
it wasn't too funny.
All right,
that's the podcast for this week.
God bless all of you guys.
Let's go ravens.
Fuck the jets and a,
I'm hoping this time next week that jets are fucking oh into and if they are all
into,
I'm telling you right now,
Rex Ryan,
I am Guaran fucking teeing.
It will cry during a press conference and he's going to be crying and his
fucking,
you know,
bodies going to be jiggling.
I hate the jets.
I hate the jets more than I hate the cold snap,
you know,
kind of helps it.
They lost to the Texans.
But yeah,
the jets,
I want nothing more than to watch them eat their fucking words.
The arrogance of that fucking team.
Look at that.
You don't even know how to behave when there's a lady in the room.
Um,
all right.
Who gives a fuck?
Ravens are gonna win tonight.
I'm going to have an extra 50 bucks in.
The Patriots are going to beat him next week.
All right?
That's what my heart says.
All right,
you guys have a good week.
Please watch my special Sunday night.
September 19th 11:00 PM okay,
got it.
Camera
[inaudible].